Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, da bin ich.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor, gestern entweder Streamsort zu machen oder endlich mal ein Video aufzunehmen, wird ja auch wieder Zeit.
Aber ich bin gestern nicht dazu gekommen, ich hab gestern den ganzen Tag Kuponetes-Stells gebastelt bei mir daheim.
Nee, ich werd jetzt nicht wie dieser Typ von YouTube, den wir manchmal gucken, drei Kuponetes-Cluster mir daheim hinstellen.
Ich bin immer noch lokal auf der VM am Basteln, einfach ein paar Sachen auszuprobieren.
Weil ich weiß, dass wir auf der neuen Arbeit, da wo ich anfange, wohl einiges neu in Kuponetes machen.
Hab ich mir gedacht, es schadet nichts, wenn man sich die Grundlagen, ich mein, managt Kuponetes kann jeder verwenden, ja.
Aber wenn man sich die Grundlagen nochmal anguckt, wie man auch da ein paar Sachen von Hand macht.
Und das ist tatsächlich auf den ersten Blick meistens sieht das recht simpel aus, aber das steckt echt im Detail, das ist ein Fass ohne Boden.
Also wenn man einmal damit anfängt, kannst du eigentlich den ganzen Tag nichts anderes machen.
Zumal eine Sache, die mir persönlich auch richtig da mal auf den Kicks geht, ist, warum muss das alles Yammel sein?
Das hat doch weder mit Adminen was zu tun, noch mit Ops, noch mit sonst was, das ist einfach nur Yammel-Engineer mittlerweile.
Du bastelst da seitenweise an Yammel rum, hast irgendeine Einrückung verkackt und du weißt nicht woran es liegt, weil es ist ja kein Fehler so richtig, wenn es unter einem anderen Key steht, aber es geht nicht.
Warte Leute, Yammel ist so ein Schrott, man.
Ich glaube ich muss mir da irgendwas anderes überlegen, dass ich gar kein Yammel mehr machen muss, weil Yammel ist einfach wirklich...
Aber das ist das einzige was sinnvoll ist, weil es ist halt native unterstützt.
Kubernetes-Yammel.
Es gibt zwar so zig andere Varianten, aber dann hast du wieder Probleme die anderweitig zu integrieren.
Man könnte in Terraform Kubernetes-Provider nehmen, man könnte irgendwelche Templating-Geschichten nehmen, man könnte das in irgendeiner Programmation machen,
Yammel ist erzeugt, aber das ist alles nicht so schön, man muss es in Yammel machen.
Und ich mag Yammel zunehmend nicht, also wie es bei euch aussieht.
Yammel ist massivster Pains-Champ.
C++ größer Yammel.
Naja ne, ganz soweit würde ich noch nicht gehen.
Der Vergleich ist ja eh schonmal geil.
Ne, ganz soweit würde ich noch nicht gehen.
C++ wird wahrscheinlich auch auf absehbare Zeit, sodass wir schissenste bleiben, was es so gibt.
Aber Yammel steigt in meinem Ranking auf.
Yammel ist eklig einfach nur.
Also es gibt eine Sache, da ist tatsächlich C++ besser als Yammel.
Du stellst relativ easy fest, ob es Syntaxfehler enthält.
Nicht Syntaxfehler, Syntaxfehler ist falsch.
Ob es, sagen wir mal, syntaktisch korrekt ist, dass es so aufgebaut ist, dass es das macht, was du denkst, dass es machen soll.
Bei Yammel hast du das Problem, also in C++ hat es keine falschen Einrückungen und sowas.
Wenn du da ne Klammer falsch machst, dann wird der ganze Block nicht ausgeführt.
Oder es gibt halt nen Syntaxfehler.
Bei Yammel gibt es viel viel seltener Syntaxfehler.
Bei Yammel gibt es eigentlich fast nie, es sei denn du verkackst die Einrückungen ganz ganz extrem.
Bei Yammel gibt es fast nie Syntaxfehler in dem Sinn.
Sondern das macht dann einfach nicht das, was du willst, weil dein Key eben nicht richtig eingerückt ist und der unter dem falschen Parent hängt.
Aber das siehst du nicht, weil wenn das Yammel-File, sagen wir mal, so ein Bildschirm lang ist, dann fällt das nicht unbedingt auf.
Da brauchst du dann in Wishful Studio irgendwelche Einrückungs-Highlighter oder sowas.
Oder du brauchst irgendein Kuponetis-Manifest-Linter.
Oder irgendein Kuponetis-Manifest-Linter.
Das ist halt richtig kacke.
Das es ssuckt.
Rust ist übrigens seit 6.1 im Kernel.
Ist das nicht schon ne Weile im Kernel?
Das wird doch schon seit 3-4 Jahren immer wieder diskutiert.
Ich dachte das ist eigentlich schon längst dabei.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, hat zwar heute Morgen brauchen wir die v.a. nicht.
Je nachdem wie weit ich heute nach dem Stream noch komme.
Also ich bin mir heute nicht sicher.
Entweder mach ich heute wirklich noch ein Video.
Oder ich bastel noch ein bisschen Kuponetis weiter.
Und dann machen wir heute Abend noch mal eine Runde Kuponetis-Stream.
Weil wir müssen noch so viele Sachen uns angucken.
Ich mach gerade mal Package-Update Leute.
Lasst euch nicht irritieren.
Nur, dass ich das nachher nicht machen muss.
Ja, sehr sinnvolles Comment.
Einmal kurz updaten, yes.
Updaten, yes.
Yes.
So.
In der Public Cloud, nein.
Aktuell probiere ich schlicht und ergreifend ein paar Sachen bei mir lokal aus.
Es macht keinen Sinn das in der Cloud zu betreiben.
Nur damit es in der Cloud läuft.
Zum ausprobieren bist du sogar schneller lokal.
Weil lokal bringt es dir nichts im Endeffekt.
Wenn du es wirklich benutzen willst.
Aber zum ausprobieren ist es ganz nice.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gestern.
Nur mal so was.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gestern Argo CD installiert.
Mit selbst discoverten Apps.
Also sprich.
Du musst jetzt nicht jede App im Web-Interface von Hand hinzufügen.
Du musst einfach nur einen Ordner anlegen mit Apps.
Und das Ding erkennt anhand eines Application-Sets.
Alle Apps in diesen Ordnern.
Und fügt die dann selbst hinzu.
Muss ich quasi nichts mehr von Hand installieren.
Sondern kann das alles über irgendwelche Git-Yammels machen.
Einfach ein neues Ordner anlegen.
Yammel reinlegen und schon wird das Ding automatisch deployed.
Minikube.
Das ist doch das einfachste für Lokale auf der VM.
Das Ding startet einfach in einen Docker-Container mit 2 CPUs und 8G RAM.
Und ich kann es jederzeit löschen und starten.
Das ist für lokal zum Basteln finde ich am besten.
Wenn man das wirklich lokal betreiben will.
Dann eher das.
Aber zum Basteln finde ich ist Minikube immer noch nice.
Es gibt auch Rancher Desktop mittlerweile.
Habe ich gesehen, dass das auch recht beliebt ist.
Aber ich meine Minikube ist top.
Da gibt es eigentlich nichts.
Wo man sich ja irgendwie groß beschwerden könnte drüber.
So, jetzt lassen wir erstmal alle Updates durchlaufen.
Wir installieren mal wieder Zeug.
Das brauchen wir heute Morgen gar nicht.
Ich mache das einfach nur, dass ich es heute Mittag nicht machen muss.
Falls wir heute Mittag streamen.
Ich hoffe ja, dass wir heute Mittag streamen können.
Bis hier ein bisschen Kubernetes-Stalls weitermachen.
Noch einen halben Monat Mittag. Ja.
Hat eigentlich der alte Arbeitgeber noch Bemühungen angestellt?
Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö.
War kaum nichts mehr.
Aber ist jetzt ja auch zu spät.
Ich habe ja im Dezember die Kündigung eingereicht.
Und das ist ja auch gelaufen.
Jetzt können die ja nichts mehr machen.
Na doch.
Sagen wir mal so.
Die könnten sagen, kommen wir wieder zurück.
Wir scheißen nicht mit Geld zu.
Dann müsste ich halt da und wieder absagen.
Und dann würde ich ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht machen.
Ich meine, selbst durch das Meer.
Also wenn die es machen würden, was sie ja nicht machen.
Also selbst wenn die mich jetzt voll zukacken würden mit Geld.
Die eigentlichen Probleme.
Also da müssten sie schon richtig krass mit Geld zukacken.
Dass ich das machen würde.
Weil die Probleme und die Sachen, die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Sind ja immer noch da.
Was bringt mir mehr Geld?
Wenn der Laden immer noch so planlos ist.
Und immer noch keine richtige Homeoffice-Regelung haben.
Die was traugt.
Ist das nicht deine Teugnung?
Nö. Warum?
Du meinst, ah.
Du meinst, weil die das da nicht wertzuschätzen wissen.
Das ist im größten Enterprise-Umfeld.
So politische Leitern, die das hoch muss wegen Gehalt.
Das hat ja nichts mit dir persönlich zu tun.
Wenn sie da nichts, nichts machen.
Ja, also da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Das ist ja, guck mal.
Der einzige, der das wirklich einschätzen kann.
Ist dein direkter Chef.
Und der kann ab einer gewissen, ja.
Größe der Firma und Hierarchie-Ebene sowas ja eh nicht selbst entscheiden.
Das heißt, selbst wenn dein Chef das nicht will, dass du gehst.
Der kann das auch nur nach oben hin verkaufen.
Und wenn dann da irgendeiner sitzt, der das nicht, nicht richtig checkt.
Dann gibt es da auch nichts.
Da würde ich mir keine.
Nö, das ist mir egal.
Schau mal.
Keine Ahnung.
Ein Prozent oder so.
0,5.
Ja, 1,3 Prozent.
Aber auch nur, weil ich es alle 0,5 refreshen lasse.
So, jetzt können wir das auch mal wieder ausmachen.
Jetzt haben wir die VM ja aktualisiert.
Wollen wir mal wieder aus.
Ups, ja.
White Papo Happy.
Lass uns gerade mal nochmal GitHub Trends gucken, was es da Neues gibt.
Lass mich raten.
AI, AI, Krypto, AI, AI, Krypto.
Okay, AI.
AI.
Ist schon klar.
AI, AI.
Okay, irgendeine Liste.
AI.
Oh, .NET.
Ach, das Zeug.
Ja, okay.
AI, AI, AI.
Okay.
.NET Backend Developer.
Was?
Ach so, von dem gucke ich manchmal die YouTube-Videos.
Ist das sein GitHub-Account?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Von dem gucke ich YouTube-Videos.
Der macht gute .NET, C-Sharp-Videos.
Ähm, so.
AI, AI.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich auch AI, AI.
Maui, Kekkel, braucht keiner.
Alter, was ist das für Spuggymusik?
Leute, Windows 11, Mann.
Es ist so kacke, Alter.
Ich dreh durch mit diesem komischen...
Ah, Mann, das ist so dumm.
Guck mal.
Das ist so dumm.
Ich weiß sogar nicht, wo ich hin muss, Mann, hier.
Man kann natürlich sagen, das liegt auch ein bisschen an den vielen Tabs.
Auch.
Aber das Problem ist, man kann nicht einfach durchtappen.
Das ist so blöde gemacht.
Und manchmal geht das auch einfach nicht.
Also das ist komplett unsinnlicher Kacke.
Okay, dieses Mal ist nichts Spannendes.
Oh, Ansible trendet mal wieder.
Oh.
Ansible.
Nee, ich nicht.
Heute nicht.
Magst du Maui nicht?
Nee, ich mochte auch schon den Vorgänger nicht.
Mich würde auch mal interessieren, ob die...
So die Adoption, wie man das so schöne...
Also ob das wirklich viel benutzt wird.
Ich meine, klar, es wird die einen oder anderen riesen Dinger damit geben, aber...
Ich hab...
Noch keinen mitbekommen, der irgendwie scharf darauf ist, was in Maui oder in Xamarin zu machen.
Ja, genau.
Also es gibt so zwei Sachen von Microsoft aus dem .NET Umfeld, wo ich nicht genau verstehe, warum...
Also doch.
Also verstehen schon, aber wo ich nicht genau nachvollziehen kann, warum die das so pushen und...
Vor allem, weil es nicht gut ankommt.
Zumindest ist es mein Eindruck, dass es nicht gut ankommt.
Das sind zwei Sachen.
Das ist einmal .NET Maui.
Das pusht Microsoft jetzt schon zwei Jahre oder so.
Und irgendwie so wirklich großartig interessieren, tut es die Leute nicht.
Klar, ein paar sind irgendwie darauf angewiesen, machen damit was.
Aber ich glaube, die meisten machen einen großen Bogen.
Ist zumindest mein Eindruck, ja.
Die meisten machen einen großen Bogen.
Und Maui, wenn sich nicht anders machen lässt.
Und das zweite ist Blazer.
Ich finde Blazer vom Ansatz her ja eigentlich ganz cool mit .NET und C Sharp eben.
Also ich meine das hier.
Ach so, die haben gar kein eigenes Repo mehr.
Okay, das ist jetzt im ASP-Repo.
Also...
Von der Idee her finde ich Blazer ja eigentlich ganz cool.
Du kannst quasi .NET...
Guckt euch das...
Nicht Razor.
Blazer.
Also ist er.
Du kannst quasi .NET im Browser laufen lassen.
Also du kannst das jetzt nicht nur serverseitig machen.
Sondern du kannst quasi mit C Sharp über WebAssembly im Browser.
Kannst du Blazer, kannst du Blazer das laufen lassen.
So, ich war da ursprünglich total begeistert.
Ich fand, ich dachte geil.
Kein JavaScript Shit mehr.
Wobei ich da halt sagen muss, dass ich in den letzten Jahren tatsächlich JavaScript...
Ja, eigentlich...
Wie soll man das nennen?
Zu mögen gelernt habe.
Also ich mag JavaScript mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gern.
Ich finde es gar nicht mehr so schlimm, dass man die Sachen in JavaScript machen muss.
So, und die Idee von Blazer ist halt, dass du mit WebAssembly, C Sharp,
beziehungsweise ein komplettes .NET-Framework im Browser benutzen kannst.
Das Blöde ist nur, dass eben, weil es WebAssembly ist,
dass so eine komische...
Also WebAssembly kann ja nicht direkt mit der Webseite interagieren.
Es muss eh über JavaScript gehen.
Das heißt im Hintergrund ist da sehr viel JavaScript-Kleber zwischen diesem C Sharp-Teil und dem Web...
Also ich finde es von der Handhabung ein bisschen hakelig.
Das was ich damit gemacht habe.
Ich habe mit Blazer nicht viel gemacht.
Wir haben mal vor Jahren im Stream ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Aber so viel habe ich dann nicht gemacht.
Aber ich finde auch die Technik nicht so geil.
Weil du musst erstmal irgendwie 15 MB .NET-Runtime im Browser herunterladen.
Man, 15 MB, Alter!
Und das in Zeiten, wo das Wichtigste ist, was es für eine Webseite gibt,
wie schnell die zum ersten Mal lädt.
Ja, in Zeiten, wo die Leute Edge-Computing, CDN-Geschichten,
Rendern, Anycast auf der Welt verteilen, was auch immer alles machen,
dass die Webseite in möglichst 20 Millisekunden den ersten Inhalt anzeigt,
kommen die an mit, lad erstmal 15 MB Runtime runter, dass es funktioniert.
Das passt überhaupt nicht in die aktuelle Zeit, Blazer.
Gut, es gibt noch die Möglichkeit, dass du Blazer serverseitig machst.
Dann geht das Ganze über eine Websocket-Verbindung, über eine Signal-A-Verbindung.
Es ist alles komisch, ich weiß nicht.
So cool ich Blazer am Anfang fand, so unsinnig finde ich es mittlerweile.
Blazer und Maui, das sind zwei Sachen, die versucht Microsoft wie verrückt zu pushen
die letzten Jahre über.
Ich habe den Eindruck, so viel Verbreitung hat beides nicht.
Und die gehen da voll drauf ab und ich finde beides auch nicht sonderlich toll.
Also keine Ahnung, was da bei Microsoft los ist.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Also ich werde es in Zukunft auch nicht verwenden.
Dann bin ich froh, dass ich mir vor einer Weile Svelte angeguckt habe.
Und warum habe ich mir Svelte angeguckt?
Warum habe ich es mir angeguckt?
Weil der Chat gesagt hat, Max, kennst du schon Svelte.js?
Oder heißt es überhaupt Svelte.js?
Svelte-Kit.
Dann habe ich gesagt, ja habe ich schon gelesen, aber noch nichts mitgemacht.
Und dann habe ich es mir angeguckt und mir gedacht, das ist doch eigentlich somit das
beste an Frontend-Framework, was man verwenden kann.
Zumal es ja gar kein Frontend-Framework ist, sondern einfach stinknormales JavaScript
am Ende rausfällt, was ohne großartige Abhängigkeiten läuft.
Das ist eigentlich eine nice Geschichte.
Es ist leider vieles Elektron, ja.
Aber es geht ja nicht so sehr um Desktop-Anwendung.
Desktop-Anwendungen sind zum größten Teil tatsächlich entweder rein webbasiert oder
eben vieles Elektron.
Wobei man sagen muss, nicht alles.
Ich meine, ein Browser selbst ist logischerweise nicht webbasiert.
Und ein paar Sachen, so wie ein Terminal und OBS und Thunderbird und was auch nicht.
Aber Discord zum Beispiel ist Elektron.
Und es gibt vieles, was Elektron ist.
Also, allerdings muss ich sagen, .NET ist für mich persönlich gar nicht mehr so sehr
interessant für Windows-Desktops.
Da kommt das vielleicht her.
Und ich fange jetzt nicht wieder mit der, ja, Etcher zum Beispiel.
Etcher ist auch Elektron.
Und ich fange jetzt nicht schon wieder an mit, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, Gedankensprung
und, ach so, ich fange jetzt nicht wieder an mit den ganzen .NET-Framework und .NET-Core
und .NET-Versionen, die es gibt.
Sondern .NET selbst finde ich persönlich jetzt auf dem Windows-Desktop nicht mehr so interessant.
Klar, es ist letztendlich, wenn man eine reine Windows-Anwendung bauen will, also wirklich
eine reine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung bauen will, ist .NET auf der einen Seite immer noch
die beste Technologie, die man verwenden kann.
Das Problem ist nur, dass alle Desktop-Framework sagen.
Ich meine, du hast Windows-Forms.
Das ist ganz okay, weil leicht gewichtig und recht simpel, dafür hoffnungslos veraltet,
auch was die Technologien angeht.
Ich meine, das siehst du daran, dass du beispielsweise in Windows-Forms noch nicht mal Emojis verwenden kannst.
Danach kommt WPF.
WPF ist auch hoffnungslos veraltet, wenn auch ein bisschen moderner in den Ansätzen, allerdings
auch hoffnungslos veraltet.
Und das neue Zeug von Microsoft hebt auch nicht so wirklich ab.
Also Microsoft hat es ja quasi geradezu heraufbeschworen, Elektron, dadurch, dass sie einfach Jahrzehnte,
kann man jetzt fast schon sagen, ich weiß nicht, wann WPF released wurde, 2005 oder
so was, dadurch, dass sie schon quasi Jahrzehnte kein ordentliches Windows-Desktop-Framework,
also das, was eigentlich eine ganze Zeit lang, was bestimmt 10, 15 Jahre lang der meistverbreitete
Desktop war und die Leute dafür was entwickeln wollten, kein geschaltes UI-Framework gab.
Es gibt nichts, es gab nichts, es gab eine Zeit lang Windows-Forms und WPF.
Kannste, kannst du knicken mittlerweile.
Und dann hat es so eine Zeit lang halt UWP.
UWP, das einzig gute an UWP war die UI-Komponenten und sogar die fand ich zwar, ja, von der Performance
und vom Rendering her und so fand ich das ganz cool.
Allerdings weder die Standard-Optik noch der ganze UWP-Rest war sonderlich gut.
Ich mein, guckt euch das Ding mal an.
Das ist eine WinUI bzw. UWP-Anwendung.
Weiß ich, ob es mittlerweile noch UWP ist.
So, ich mein, seriously, da sind ein paar coole Sachen dabei, aber es sieht halt auf der einen
Seite mega, ich weiß nicht, UWP bzw.
WinUI, das ist so eine Kombination aus.
Es hat wirklich Sachen, die sehr cool sind.
Und auf der anderen Seite sieht es halt einfach nur mega billig aus.
Alles klar.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal zum Beispiel schon an, dieses komische Highlight-Ding hier oben.
Und wenn du rausklickst, wenn du rausklickst, ist es weg.
Was ist das, Mann?
Was ist das?
Das hier neben und so, das ist eher eine Web, das ist eher eine Mobile-Anwendung anstatt,
dass man das auf dem Desktop haben will.
Und auch dieses Skalieren, das ist, ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie Müll.
Dafür hat WinUI bzw. das UI-Framework, was unter UWP drunter war, was jetzt zum größten
Teil WinUI 3 immer noch ist, schon mal ganz coole Sachen.
Ich meine, guckt mal, ihr seht den Hintergrund hier durchschimmern.
Ihr seht den Hintergrund hier durchschimmern.
Und das ist nicht einfach.
Nur Transparenz, wie euch vielleicht auffällt.
Ja, guckt mal.
Es ist nicht nur Transparenz, sondern es ist Transparenz im Hintergrund, die angepasst ist.
Mal gucken, ob man das, man sieht das, man sieht das ein bisschen.
Ja, es ist Transparenz, die angepasst ist.
Wait a minute.
Das ist nicht, das ist gar nicht, das ist fake.
Guck mal, das haben die umgebaut.
Das ist mein Desktop-Hintergrund, den man da immer noch hat.
Nicht den, nicht den Browser.
Okay, das ist, das ist mies.
Ja, aber was ich sagen wollte, eine coole Sache ist zum Beispiel, dass sie zwar etwas
Transparenz im Hintergrund haben, aber die Transparenz sich anpasst, je nachdem, wie
die Farben im UI sind, sodass es eben immer genug Kontrast hat.
Also, da haben die schon was bei gedacht.
Aber ich meine, guck mal, das sieht einfach nur billig aus.
Ich glaube, das ist der beste Ausdruck.
Es sieht billig aus.
Es sieht aus wie ohne, obwohl es, obwohl eine Design-Philosophie dahinter ist.
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Elemental UI.
Ne, wie heißt das Ding von Microsoft?
Keine Ahnung, dieses Flat Designing, ist es Elemental UI?
Ne.
Obwohl eine Design-Philosophie dahinter ist, wie man ja eindeutig auch sieht, dass es unterschiedlich
Kontrast gibt, sieht es halt einfach nur billig aus.
Sieht einfach nur billig aus.
Technologisch ist das cool.
Das ist schnell.
Das ist sehr snappy in der Bedienung.
Die Startzeiten sind schnell.
Das Front-Rendering ist mittlerweile auch relativ gut.
Relativ, relativ gut.
Nicht, nicht überall.
Und das ist okay.
Aber Microsoft hat es halt einfach 20 Jahre, 15 Jahre verkackt.
Gescheites UI-Framework raus.
Und selbst jetzt ist das nicht, ist das nicht mal gescheit, weil sie immer noch das Legacy
von UWP-Zeuchen, Fluent-Design, nicht Element-Design, Fluent-Design.
Ja, genau, richtig, das meine ich.
Weil sie immer noch so die Legacy-Sachen von UWP dabei haben, zum Beispiel, dass man
lange Zeit keine Unpackaged-Applications machen konnte.
Das heißt, jemand, der einen Taschenrechner programmieren wollte für Windows, jetzt
haltet euch mal fest, der musste sich, damit er das, wir reden hier nicht vom Vertreiben
über den Windows-Store.
Über den Windows-Store-Vertreiben ist mittlerweile tatsächlich unproblematischer geworden.
Ich rede hier einfach von einem Open Source-Projekt auf GitHub, wo du dann auf Release klickst
und dir die Anwendung runterladen kannst oder einen Installer, was auch immer.
Zumindest jemand, der so eine kleine Hilfsanwendung baut, sagen wir mal einen Windows-Taschenrechner,
der musste sich ernsthaft jahrelang oder muss ich das immer noch, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie gut Unpackaged-Applications funktionieren, der musste sich ein Codesigning-Zertifikat
kaufen für 250 Euro im Jahr, dass der überhaupt Anwendungen rausspringen konnte, die nicht
beim Installieren gewarnt haben, Achtung, kein gültiges Zertifikat beziehungsweise
ein extra Zertifikat-Installationsschritt erfordert haben, was niemand gecheckt hat.
Also so nach dem Motto, wie man das früher kannte, bei beispielsweise einer Windows-Forms-Anwendung
runterladen und starten, war da nicht. Ja, okay, man kann sagen, das ist ja ein Sicherheitsfeature,
weil wer ein Codesigning-Zertifikat hat, hat ein Codesigning-Zertifikat, hat schon mal
Geld für ausgegeben, weil es ja auch kein richtiges Sicherheitsfeature ist, weil auch
Meldungenentwickler können sich ein Codesigning-Zertifikat irgendwie besorgen, aber im Endeffekt hat
es dazu geführt, dass die Leute immer noch Oldschool Unpackaged Win32-Apps gemacht haben,
weil man eben einfach wollte, dass ich hier meine Anwendung runterladen kann und sie
dann auch benutzen, ja, und du kein Codesigning-Zertifikat als Hobbyentwickler mit einem kleinen
Projekt auf GitHub haben wolltest. Also Microsoft hat es da wirklich 15 Jahre lang mega verkackt,
was Desktop-Anwendung anbelangt hat und deswegen bin ich eigentlich überzeugt, von dass es
ein großer Teil dazu beigetragen hat, natürlich auch das Browser und alles besser geworden
sind, aber dass Electron zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort war und auch dieses Vakuum
mitgefüllt hat auf dem Windows-Desktop. Das schöne an Electron nebenbei war, dass du dann
dadurch Electron-Anwendungen packagen konntest, die auf Windows liefen, auf Linux und Mac
liefen und theoretisch mit ein bisschen Zeug auch, wenn man will, mobile. Das war natürlich
auch ein weiterer Punkt, aber die haben es einfach verkackt. Und deswegen sehe ich tatsächlich
auch, wenn du für eine reine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung theoretisch das mit .NET immer noch am besten
machen kannst, gibt es kein gescheites UI-Framework. Und was, wenn du Windows-Desktop-Anwendung
machen willst, willst du ja meistens eine UI-Anwendung machen, also eine grafische
Oberfläche. Und das ist erst die letzten ein, zwei Jahre ein bisschen besser geworden mit
WinUI 3 und das geht jetzt halbwegs. Also wenn du was wirklich in System integriertes
machen willst und was, was Windows-Funktionen benutzt, ist .NET unter Windows rein, für
Windows immer noch das Beste, aber vielfach fährst du tatsächlich mit Electron oder
irgendwas anderem in der Richtung besser. Für mich persönlich ist .NET dementsprechend
mal kurz ein bisschen leiser machen. Deswegen ist .NET für mich gar nicht mehr so relevant,
also für mich persönlich, ich mache ja keine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung mehr. Für Windows-Desktop-Anwendung
sondern, wo ich .NET wirklich sehr gerne verwende, sind Kommandozeilen Tools, Metro-UI, Moment,
war Metro-UI nicht FluentUI für WPF, aber das ist ja immer noch das Problem, dass du
WPF drunter hast. Ja, also ich mag .NET gerne für Konsolen-Anwendung, was ich mal im Beruf
oft habe, für Automatisierung oder irgendwelche Hilfstools oder Kleinigkeiten, wo mal schnell
was gemacht werden muss, aber das mache ich tatsächlich in .NET ganz gerne. Ich finde
immer noch, dass C-Sharp für mich persönlich die angenehmste Programmiersprache ist. Klar,
ich mag es auch, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich was mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich was mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache,
wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache,
oder etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn
ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache,
wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache,
wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas Apache
mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas
mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich etwas mache, wenn ich als
das heißt, es hat schon seinen Sinn sowas ist eine sehr coole Geschichte, aber ich finde
gerade in der heutigen Zeit von von Microservices und Containerisierung ist es gar nicht mehr
unbedingt notwendig, dass man sich so sehr auf das muss jetzt alles verfügbar sein für meine
Entwicklung, für meine Umgebung, für meine Programmiersprache, sondern man kann ja die
Sachen auch ganz gut mischen und aus dem Gesichtspunkt muss ich sagen fürs Backend finde
ich ist dort net aktuell das Beste für meinen Geschmack das Beste was es gibt so ungeschlagen
asp.net hat so ein bisschen den den Ruf von früher ich mein db navigator war da nicht früher
auch in asp in einem old school was zum wahren frankfurt nach offenbach weiß ich ob das noch
so ist was ist das ok ich ich bilde mir ein der kran war früher im alten asp.net ja dann
tut er für den zapp so und asp.net hat einen kack ruf aber das liegt daran dass das noch aus
zeiten ist von windows server wie war das form server pages und asp 6 und so was das war wirklich
schrottig microsoft hätte glaube ich gut dran getan asp.net core was hier eine komplette
neuentwicklung ist mit asp gar nichts mehr zu tun hat microsoft benahmung at its best halt
die hätten wirklich gut getan dem irgendwie einen coolen neuen namen zu geben dotnet web oder
irgendwie sowas oder blazingly fast written in c sharp aber dem haftet immer noch an das asp so
unbeliebt so gesagt hat ja ich finde für wie gesagt für web backends ist für mich für meinen
dotnet immer noch ungeschlagen und das beste auch für mich was es gibt gerade die kombination
aussicht ab als programmiersprache recht guter performance was microsoft sich dazu recht
fantasiert ist natürlich auch absolut lächerlich dotnet asp performance benchmark microsoft
fantasiert sich da ja irgendein schwachsinn zusammen totaler totaler blödsinn also laut
laut microsoft ist ja asp asp.net core also das web framework im dass das das dotnet web
framework ist ja das schnellste was es gibt ja nix ist schneller so und das ding ist halt nur
oder es ist einer der schnellsten überhaupt microsoft Microsoft fantasiert sich da übelsten
blödsinn zusammen und zwar hat microsoft custom framework code custom code für diesen benchmark
entwickelt so und die stehen da zwar drinne mit asp asp.net core ist ganz oben es wird aber nichts
von asp.net core verwendet um diese betten jetzt machen in dieser form machen es tatsächlich
nicht alle und also die sagen ja wir sind asp.net core aber es wird um diese benchmark ergebnisse
zu erreichen fast nichts von asp.net core verwendet es werden hardcoded responses benutzt und so was
das geht überhaupt nicht durch das framework durch es ist es ist es ist halt irgendwo bisschen
bisschen beschiss aber die performance ist trotzdem gut deswegen muss man auch mal sagen
microsoft hätte das eigentlich gar nicht notwendig mit mit asp.net core ich weiß nicht ob die hier
nicht vielleicht auch mal wieder irgendwelche benchmarks microsoft zeigt diese benchmark
ergebnisse gerne ja ich kann euch die webseite auch mal zeigen wo es die gibt web framework
wie hieß denn diese seite noch mal das da vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile auch
mittlerweile auch bereinigt auch keine ahnung wo muss man denn hin
vielleicht haben sie es vielleicht haben sie es auch bereinigt sonst sonst auch mal also ich
habe keine ahnung was microsoft da immer in ihren in ihren talks zeigt es ist auf jeden fall hier
irgendwas irgendwas hier vorn ist es die webseite funktioniert richtig da sind die immer sind die
immer ganz ganz weit vorne man sieht ja auch hier guck mal das ist hier nicht ist ja auch
nicht viel unterschied so da sind da sind die immer ganz plaintext 3 plaintext und jetzt
um ok zeigt mal die seite ist kaputt wo muss ich klicken plaintext
ok jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich gebrake die webseite
ach keine zumindest was ich eigentlich sagen wollte man sieht ja hier microsoft wirbt ja
selbst damit dass sie dass sie total total geil sind und und weit oben und so was so das ist halt
das ist halt richtig richtig zurecht gefegt die dabei hätten sie das ist was ich sagen wollte
dabei hätten sie es eigentlich gar nicht nötig das ganze zu faken weil würden sie sich mal
realistische würde würden sie mal realistische benchmarks machen nämlich als full featured
framework also sprich dass du dort halt auch relativ easy und schnell und entwickler freundlich
api web services und sowas entwickeln kannst dafür wie gut das und easy das von der hand geht ist die
performance nämlich wirklich gut da kannst du dich überhaupt nicht beschweren du kannst jetzt ja in
so einem benchmark du kannst es zwar vergleichen aber es macht keinen sinn du kannst du kannst
jetzt ja da nicht ordentlich vergleichen quasi den webservice der hardcoded html zurückgibt versus
den webservice der dynamisch mit kontrollern die response erzeugt ja ist ja logisch dass
hardcoded das programm mit den hardcoded responses nur für diesen benchmark ist super schnell in
diesem benchmark kann aber sonst nichts die andere anwendung die das dynamisch generiert
die benchmark ergebnis die könnt ihr für alles andere auch verwenden und da würde dort net gar
nicht so schlecht dastehen deswegen verstehe ich nicht was ihr rum gefake soll an der stelle die
würden auch so ganz gut dastehen so deswegen mag ich dort net für backend anwendung einfach
weil es schnell ist weil es sie scharpe eine super programmiersprache hat einfach zu benutzen ist
das ökosystem recht gut ist natürlich kann man das nicht vergleichen mit sagen wir mal javascript
oder auch teilweise mit wie viele 30 milliarden go packages und sowas es mittlerweile gibt oder
auch was es teilweise für für für python packages gibt es hat es hat unterschiedliche unterschiedliche
schwerpunkte es gibt für dort net aber auch nahezu alles was man braucht das muss man muss
sagen und je nachdem welche technik man einsetzen will muss es auch nicht dort net sein also wenn
man jetzt machine learning sachen machen will und die besten libraries die man benötigt gibt
für python dann macht es ja keinen sinn dann dass irgendwie in dort net zu zu zwingen das
ist aber heutzutage nicht schlimm weil man kann ohne probleme das web backend in dort net machen
und den machine learning part in python das muss ja nicht alles mehr in einer anwendung sein die
so und deswegen interessiert man sich immer noch sollte man sich immer noch für dort net
interessieren weil es ein super framework ist mit einer super programmiersprache was von einem
riesen unternehmen supported ist was morgen auch nicht weg ist du kannst davon sicher sein wenn
irgendwas in der dort net standard library ist dann ist das auch morgen noch da für irgendwelche
python rust go packages gilt das nicht zwangsläufig natürlich wenn sie noch standard
library ist schon aber es ist einfach sehr umfangreich die dort net standard library
wenn ich andere programmiersprachen benutze frage ich mich auch manchmal warum ist das warum
ist das nicht drinne zum beispiel letztens haben wir was in python gebastelt und da ist mir
aufgefallen dass python keine gescheite date time klasse hat du hast zwar time delta aber
was ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher was wir für probleme hatten aber du konntest
heim delta glaube ich nicht ordentlich formatieren weil es keine keine formatmöglichkeiten hatte
oder irgendwie so was also es war es war relativ eklig ich will nicht sagen dass die time handling
jetzt super schön ist in der dort net standard nein nein dort net standard ist duplicate es
geht um die standard library von dort net von dort net nicht um dort net standard was wieder
was anderes ist weil microsoft benahmung und die ist schon relativ relativ nice also für
beckens finde ich ist dort net eine super geschichte für frontend sachen heute eher weniger und der
dritte punkt wo ich dort net auch mag ist für cloud functions wenn man es verwendet wohl gemerkt
ich glaube außer in edge also überall anders nicht so geil überall anders muss man glaube
ich dort netz sachen dann in irgendeinem container workload oder so laufen lassen aber in edge ist
dort net natürlich eine super geschichte für funktions kann go eigentlich auch nicht go
ok guck mal google cloud kann es auch aber aws aws kann es nicht oder doch aws ok habe ich
nichts gesagt dann können sie alle drei großen cloud anbieter mittlerweile ja dann ist kein
problem dann bilden wir ein das ist noch nicht immer so gewesen ja das ist nice wenn es wenn
das mittlerweile sogar bei google cloud geht ja cool sehr schön ja sehr nice dass das auch geht
ja und für sowas ist dort net auch nice weil eben es die scharpner schöne programmiersprache
ist und das ist auch wieder in cloud funktions ist es wirklich sind es wirklich gut weil dort
netz hat ein paar vorteile also die kombination die die kombination und ist ist für cloud
funktions tatsächlich ganz nice und zwar die performance ist gut die startup time wenn man
es richtig macht ist auch ok und sie schab ist eine super programmiersprache deswegen eignet
sich das finde ich auch ganz gut für cloud funktions man kann natürlich sagen ok wenn
es richtig super krass performance sein soll und auch die startup zeiten super gering sein soll
dann wäre jetzt dort net vielleicht für cloud funktions nicht das beste aber sie sind ja auf
einem guten weg dahin sie haben jetzt in dort net acht wird es viel mehr geben für ahead of
time compilation also quasi das was man so unter unter kompilieren versteht quasi auf
den compile klopf drücken es kommt in den binary raus das geht ja jetzt schon mit dort net auch
schon teilweise also ich rede jetzt nicht hier so ein self contain zipp was dort net schon lange
kann sondern wirklich native executables das geht ja jetzt schon auch aber hat noch ein paar hat
noch ein paar probleme mit dort nach wird das deutlich besser und dann ist natürlich auch sowohl
die start performance als auch die runtime performance super geschichte auch für cloud
funktions also ich denke es schadet auf jeden fall nicht sich mit sie schab und dort net zu
beschäftigen das kann eigentlich nur von vorteil sein wenn man da ein bisschen plan hat so jetzt
habe ich ewig geschwätzt habe 30 minuten oder so dazu aber da muss halt mal gesagt werden ich
darf darf auf der arme noch angela gs machen ist angela gs noch das ganz ganz alte oder ist das
schon das neue ich glaube angela ist das neue angela gs ist das alte dieses ganz das von 2014
oder so ganz alt nice etcher etcher etcher ist auch elektron wobei so leute ihr könnt auch
einfach wenn ihr keinen bock habt auf etcher warum ist denn jetzt meine vm bitteschön aus
wenn ihr keinen bock auf etcher habt und linux verwendet wohlgemerkt nur wenn nur wenn ihr linux
benutzt dann könnt ihr auch anstatt etcher wenn ihr keinen bock habt elektron zu starten
oder elektron zu verwenden
kurz nass putzen wenn ihr keinen bock habt elektron zu verwenden könnt ihr auch einfach
also hier etcher etcher könnt ja ich habe das sim link lull ne nicht zum link ich hab das ali
aliast ihr könnt ja auch usb imager verwenden ja alter usb usb imager ist quasi auch bisschen
wie etcher nur schneller native und nur 5 mb groß man kann es hier in den iso auswählen
ich habe kein iso windows 11 iso auswählen usb stick auswählen draufhauen allerdings
etcher kann man auch benutzen ist auch ok ehrlich gesagt ist es mit etcher gar nicht so verkehrt
weil da braucht 500 mb für nen flash programm aber man macht sie auch gleich wieder aus
ja leider leider ich glaube eh dass sie sich mit view 3 kein großen gefallen getan haben view 3
hat coole coole änderungen ja ist ein bisschen in manchen stellen mehr relect like gewesen dd kann
man auch benutzen wenn wenn du damit ok bist dass du beim kleinen verschreiber vielleicht eine
festplatte überschreibt aber dd ist auch ok kann man auch machen du musst dir nur sicher sein dass
dein device auf dass du dd ist das richtige ist dann ist kein ding ja ich glaube die haben sich
mit view 3 generell keinen gefallen getan die haben ein paar coole sachen eingebaut die haben
aber halt sehr vieles umgestrickt klar die variante wie man in view 2 eine anwendung erstellt hat geht
in view 3 immer noch also ganz immer noch options api und sowas verwenden aber es hat sich auch die
empfehlung geändert ich glaube die haben viele die haben viel momentum ja viel schwung verloren bei
view 2 auf view 3 kam mir zumindest so vor ich weiß ich wie du das siehst ja oder für wie alle
view view benutzer dass das einschätzen oder langjährige benutzer das einschätzen also falls
jemand view benutzt könnt ihr meinen chat schreiben ob ihr das auch denkt also ich habe den ein und
wir haben viel schwung verloren von view 2 zu view 3 das problem was mit react in dem fall nicht
react macht laufen irgendwas kaputt react ist halt einfach das verbreitetste größte und mehr und
mehr rolling release quasi ja und heutzutage hat windows forms mehr oder weniger wpf sogar
überlebt das sind keine elektronen apps das sind pws elektronen apps sind verpackte browser du
meinst pws also progressive web apps quasi webseiten die du dir als desktop anwendung
installieren kannst mit einem click hier oben irgendwo drauf kannst ja zum beispiel youtube
kannst du ja hier das meinst du das ist so pws das ist das was apple mit safari immer noch nicht
ordentlich unterstützt es geht zwar mittlerweile aber es fehlen immer noch dinger
dankeschön für den sub pogu
nee hat es nicht du hast den pisen time delta habe ich ja auch gerade gesagt ja aber damit
kannst du kein time delta gescheit formatieren und dann hast du so sachen wie time delta rest
und sowas was auch nicht richtig funktioniert ich habe es letztens zusammen mit euch im stream
gemacht also dass der time handling in python war etwas painstampig was haltet ihr von bootstrap
ist die verwendung noch empfehlenswert oder ist das framework mittlerweile veraltet also
veraltet insofern dass es wird immer noch entwickelt und ist immer noch saumäßig beliebt
ich meine persönliche meinung ist dass bootstrap eigentlich fast schon wieder besser zu verwenden
ist heutzutage als noch vor ein paar jahren weil also hat mehrere gründe erstens haben sie ihren
ganzen jquery shit rausgeschmissen mittlerweile glaube ich zumindest leute haben die ich glaube
schon ich glaube jquery shit ist mittlerweile raus und warum bootstrap warum ich bootstrap
heute wieder ein bisschen cooler finde als vor ein paar jahren ist weil nicht mehr jede
webseite heute auszieht aussieht wie bootstrap so 2016 rum so 2000 so 2014 15 16 so in dem da
sei ja jede webseite aus wie bootstrap jede webseite sei eins zu eins aus dem bootstrap
baukasten aus also damals war so der coole look bootstrap like auszusehen und das fand
ich damals schon total beknackt dass jede webseite aussieht wie wie wenn sie bootstrap verwendet
was wahrscheinlich viele webseiten damals auch gemacht haben das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr
so mittlerweile sehen viele webseiten etwas individuell aus das heißt wenn man heute
bootstrap verwendet ist das nicht mehr so dass seine webseite exakt aussieht wie die 99 davor
was passiert eigentlich im hintergrund gerade
nintendo tos
ich sollte doch letztes jahr im februar schon rauskommen version 3
ja gut das kann man ja nicht wirklich vergleichen die zwei tailwind ist ja eher für leute die
kein bock haben css zu schreiben aber ihr design selbst machen wollen und bootstrap ist für leute
die fertige fertige funktionalität und design haben wollen also mit tailwind musst du ja immer
noch deine webseite selbst designen nur dass du inline schreiben kannst in im class tag anstatt
dass du extra css schreiben muss bei bootstrap ist die sache ja schon fix und fertig und du
machst button und das sieht dann aus wie bootstrap button habe ich mir nur kurz angeguckt war ganz
ok kann jetzt ich kann jetzt nicht viel viel zu sagen
ja so sieht es aus leute ich habe ein problem bevor wir jetzt anfangen uns ein paar videos zu
geben ich habe ein problem ich muss mal kurz
afklo ich bin gleich wieder da zwei minuten oder fünf oder so mal gucken ich beeile mich
ich mache euch ich mache euch ich brauche ich die passende
so ich bin gleich wieder da
ja
ich bin wieder am start
kuba nee das wird diploid
so excellent
genug kirby
korrekt
möglich ja ich meine es kann ja auch sein dass sich mein eintritt mein eintrott täuscht
wobei ich sagen würde was was web frameworks angeht die meisten dürften wahrscheinlich react
leute suchen react ist ja immer noch mit abstand das größte frontend frontend framework gefolgt
von tja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich angular würde es im büsse enterprise umfeld ja
verbreitungstechnisch auf jeden fall eher gefolgt von view anstatt von angular aber im enterprise
können wir noch mal machen so vermark es gab es gibt doch dieses google google vergleich
dings trends genau da konnte man doch da konnte man doch zum beispiel jetzt rücker react so
interesse im zeitlichen deutschland weltweit
react vergleichen mit svelts ne svelts js
vergleichen mit
engel und js und vergleichen mit view js
die letzten fünf jahre
ok
das ist jetzt nicht so super repräsentativ kann man das vielleicht auch irgendwie groß machen
irgendwie so na gut das so mich halt mal ran so ran gesummt werden also man sieht eine sache react
ist eindeutig immer noch der absolute king was das angeht und tatsächlich ist seit ein paar
jahren view js im internet beliebter als angular ok svelts das welt interessiert immer noch niemand
svelte ist ein bisschen hochgegangen hier jetzt die letztes letzte jahr über
ja ich muss aber nach javascript suchen ich habe hinter alles js gemacht was soll ich
suchen ich meine wenn ich nach react suche dann ist react ja nun mal wirklich eindeutig ganz weit
oben ich kann ich nach react so ich muss muss ich habe wir können wir können nach
javascript oder so suchen ja
wobei man ganz ehrlich ich glaube das wort gibt es doch ansonst gar nicht oder
wir brauchen aber irgendwas was wir dabei alles einschränken ist doch egal ob das jetzt ein
altes framework war oder nicht der wird ja auch wenn ich angular wenn ich angular js suche findet
er ja auch weil javascript ist neu ja das ist er macht macht nicht viele unterschiedlich glaube
so trifft es wahrscheinlich sogar besser also man sieht man sieht react ist eindeutig der king
was das angeht aus irgendwelchen gründen ging ab 2001 ab 2021 alles total hoch aber svelte
juckt immer noch nicht groß eigentlich was ich cool finde ist dass hier sieht man es hier sieht
man es auch ganz gut ja also es ist es ist react es ist react angular view und dann ein
bisschen ganze ecke drunter drunter svelte ja hinweis eine verbesserung unseres datenerfassungssystem
angewandt ok ja alles klar diese google trends geschichten sind nicht so wirklich gut weil
react an sich ist halt ein begriff den findest du milliardenfach im internet
wir machen javascript dahinter ansonsten
jQuery und erst ihr müsst euch mal überlegen erst ab ab ab 2022 oder so ist react an jQuery
vorbeigezogen wenn wir jetzt mal so suchen
hallo
muss man da enta drücken für
es ist immer ein bisschen die frage wie man danach sucht
da ist ja einfach mal view total weit oben weil halt ein einzelnes wort ist halt misst
wenn man nicht genau ist es gut vergleichen kann deswegen war der name plus javascript
dahinter schon gar nicht so blöd
npm drin sagen auch jetzt so also was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an das mal gucken was haben
lohnt sich die vier tage woche ok das hat nur 120 100 200 270 views aber da bin ich mal gespannt
was er sagt wahrscheinlich drei minuten das können wir gucken lohnt sich die für tage
woche leute ihr wisst dass ich selbst vier tage woche arbeite seit vor wahrscheinlich schon fast
zehn jahren mittlerweile würde ich sagen es gab noch letztens ich habe übrigens wieder mal
entdeckt dass die vier tage woche alles besser macht es war letztens wieder gender gap day oder
irgendwie sowas und wie das so ist ist natürlich twitter komplett eskaliert bei diesem thema man
kennt es ist twitter und da wurde eine statistik gezeigt wo wir wieder aufgefallen ist dass die
vier tage woche alles besser macht moment kann ich euch kann ich euch zeigen und zwar über das
thema kann man sich vortrefflich streiten aber was man in dieser statistik sieht ist dass
männer im durchschnitt mehr arbeiten und das männer im durchschnitt mehr arbeiten und deswegen
auch mehr geld bekommen das ist das was diese statistik sagt also hätte man eigentlich auch
von ausgehen können sprich wenn jemand länger arbeitet mehr arbeitet dann kriegt er mehr geld
na gut kann natürlich auch sein dass da noch die männer jobs überdurchschnittlich bezahlt sind
das sieht man hier alles in der statistik nicht aber man sieht anzahl der bezahlten arbeitsstunden
so und wisst ihr was das einfachste wäre wenn jetzt einfach alle männer nur noch vier tage woche
arbeiten würden easy alles erledigt dann sind die männer auch hier easy dann haben zwar alle
weniger geld aber es ist ziemlich ausgeglichen die statistik und auch an dem stelle muss man
sagen vier tages woche würde es für alle beteiligten besser machen außer für die die
dann zu wenig geld haben vor allem hat man vier tage woche mehr zeit um sich alles zu kümmern
und mehr zeit das zu machen worauf man bock hat und überhaupt überhaupt mehr zeit ich könnte
beispielsweise gar nicht youtube stremen basteln groß machen wenn ich fünf tage machen würde
den zusammenhang muss jetzt mal erklären du hast wenn du vier tage woche arbeitest ein tag
mehr zeit das zu machen worauf du bock hast oder was war daran jetzt nicht zu verstehen
oder müssen wir in deine telegram gruppe wurde uns erklärt wie man wenn man genug
haschelt wenn man das passende high performer mindset hat dann gar nicht mehr arbeiten muss
und trotzdem 10.000 euro passives einkommen im monat macht
ja ich weiß mein mindset ist nicht richtig gesettet das ist schon klar mein mindset ist
nicht im high performance high performer modus also da können wir mal auf die vier tage woche ob
das die vier tage woche sich lohnt ja die vier tage woche lohnt sich ich sage euch das mal aus
meiner sicht wie gesagt ich arbeite seit bei den meisten reicht es einfach nicht vom geld
ja das stimmt wohl hast recht ich würde gar nicht sagen bei den meisten aber auf jeden fall bei
vielen ja bei den meisten würde ich sagen reicht es aber bei vielen reicht es auch nicht und das
ist natürlich problematisch gerade kenne das von einem der der arbeit jetzt nicht mehr dort aber
der hat mir das mal erzählt die haben sich halt ein haus gekauft mit mit familie und allem und
da sieht man hat man wieder wie ungewiss das ist beziehungsweise wie schnell das komplett
zum bankrot führen kann die haben sich ein haus gekauft und die planung ist irgendwie dass sie
das irgendwie bis zur bis kurz vor der rente ab bezahlt haben der typ ist keine ahnung auch 35
der kann doch jetzt nicht 30 jahre lang ein haus ab bezahlen überlegt euch das mal klar ich mein
viel wird ihm nicht mit dem gehalt nicht übrig bleiben wahrscheinlich ist auch ein ordentliches
haus aber trotzdem 30 jahre du weißt doch schon nicht mal was in fünf jahren ist wie willst du
das planen können auf 30 jahren überlegt ihr mal überlegt ihr mal die haben keinen bock mehr
aufeinander und dann das ist total gar nicht gar nicht einfach gar nicht du kannst 30 jahre
überhaupt nicht richtig planen
du weißt du weißt du nicht mal was in fünf jahren ist und du hast einfach 30 30 jahre 30
jahre was an der backe ja und der hat auch das problem der kann nicht teilzeit aber das sei dann
er kriegt eine super krasse gehalt erhöhen und dann wird er wahrscheinlich weiter fünf tage
arbeiten nur um das schneller ab bezahlen zu können ja so also gucken wir uns das mal an also
wie gesagt aus meiner sicht lohnt sich die vier tage woche für alle die sich das leisten können
es ist nicht wirklich so viel weniger geld also es ist nicht so dass man das krass spürt wenn man
eben so schon ganz gut über die runde kommt bei mir ist es halt so ihr kennt mich ich gebe
eigentlich so gut wie kein geld aus für fast nix das ist ja eh generell der der trick um
genug geld zu haben ist mehr geld behalten als auszugeben und unterm strich lohnt sich für mich
und ich würde sagen für die für die allermeisten die wo das finanziell nicht das problem ist und
dort wo es vielleicht ein problem ist muss man wirklich mal rechnen ob es echt wirklich ein
problem ist weil man denkt jetzt vielleicht ja auch nur es ist ein problem wie hast du dein
haus finanziert ich habe das haus einfach geerbt da wusste ich das nicht man zieren
just just erben pfeiffert easy life hack aber leute ich gebe ja ich gebe kaum geld aus ja das
einzige wo ich aktuell regelmäßig geld ausgebe was ausgeben jetzt wirklich anführungszeichen zu
sehen ist ist ich bezahle regelmäßig in meinen world etf ein
ja ok leute ja es ist eine berechtigte frage das ok dann werde ich euch jetzt genau meine
verwandtschaftsverhältnisse erklärt also kurz gesagt mein father hat es nicht geerbt weil
es nicht der opa von väterlicher seite sondern von mütterlicher seite ist dem das haus gehört hat
dem hat das haus gehört der hat das haus von seinem opa oder oma opa geerbt und jetzt
kam das dann zu uns so also es ist folgendermaßen ich habe es gar nicht geerbt meine mutter hat
das haus geerbt ist nicht so dass mir das haus gehört zur zeit ist es ist nicht so ja ich
wohne hier zwar mittlerweile seit 2013 aber es gehört mir nicht sonst müsste ich auch
steuern geschicht geschichten und und grunddings und wie heißt das zensus sachen machen und so
aber nachdem ich ihr einziges kind bin
ich mein irgendwann werde ich das auch er haben deswegen habe ich diesen punkt einfach
schon mal übersprungen ja das haus gehört mir aktuell nicht aber ich wüsste nicht was
dazwischen kommen sollte dass mir das mal gehört
ja und außerdem ist das ein thema da will ich das da denke ich ehrlich gesagt auch ungern
drüber nach ich mein wer macht sich gerne gedanken drüber dass die eltern sterben oder
sowas es ist ja ein sehr unangenehmes thema da willst du nicht jeden tag dran denken deswegen
sage ich einfach ja ich habe das haus geerbt habe das haus noch nicht geerbt meine mutter
hat das haus geerbt wahrscheinlich werde ich irgendwann mal erben ja und mein father in
der richtung von dem werde ich wahrscheinlich nix erben außer schulden ich war zumindest voll
aus leute cringe habe ich euch weiß gar nicht ob ich das erzählen soll dass das mein father
öfters mal irgendwelche dinge erzählt die nicht stimmen habe ich euch ja schon erzählt
also mein father kommt prinzipiell immer nur an start wenn er geld braucht also normalerweise
ist es ja eher so dass wenn die kinder probleme haben sie vielleicht mal zu ihren eltern gehen
und sagen hey mama papa guck mal ich habe hier scheiße gebaut könnt ihr mir helfen dann machen
das und dann machen das die eltern meistens auch bei mir und meinem father ist das umgedreht mein
father kommt eigentlich immer nur zu mir wenn er geld braucht so und der denkt sich ja dann auch
immer irgendwelche stories aus warum er geld braucht also meine die mit abstand abgedrehteste
story die er mal erzählt hat war das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen er hat sich gemeldet bei
mir und hat gemeint er ist in der karibik in der dominikanischen republik oder so war das glaube
ich ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das als dritte welt zählt aber irgendwie nicht weit nicht weit
davon entfernt so und dann meldet er sich bei mir und sagt ich muss ich muss ihm geld überweisen
leben deine eltern noch zusammen nein nein nein schon ewig nicht mehr der kerl ist abgehauen da
war ich drei oder so oder abgehauen abgehauen ist das falsche wort ab abgehauen ist das falsche
wort der ist nach polen abgehauen und hatte dort eine freundin von der meine mutter nichts wusste
und als meine mutter das mitgekriegt hat hat sie ihn rausgespissen verständlicherweise ja
selbst schuld naja zumindest ja kurz kippen holen naja der hat damals ein scheiß erzählt man so
nach dem motto ist auf geschäftsreise in polen und irgendwie hat er sich nie gemeldet und die
haben schon die dachte schon eben ist was passiert ja weil er hat auch immer große klappe gehabt die
dachte halt ihm ist was passiert weil er sich nicht gemeldet hat und das schlimme war alle wussten
dass er dort eine freundin hat plus sie nicht ja also alle anderen wussten es bis dann irgendwann
die frau von seinem bruder das meiner mutter gesteckt hatte dass er in polen ist und dort
eine freundin hat und daraufhin hat sie ihn halt rausgeschmückt muss hier gar nicht mehr reinkommen
ja und dann war und dann war er halt fort ja hat auch kein unterhalt mehr bezahlt und solche
geschichten also den kerl konnte komplett vergessen zumindest der meldet sich bei mir prinzipiell nur
wenn er geld braucht aktuell so und da hat er mich hat er sich an mich gewandt und mein max
muss mir geld geben ich bin hier in der ich bin hier in der karibik und ich wurde entführt ohne
scheiß leute stellt euch mal vor euer vater ruft euch an und sagt ihr müsst löse geld für ihn
bezahlen weil er in der karibik entführt wurde es klingt abgedreht aber es war so es war so
er hat gesagt er wurde entführt und er braucht löse geld 500 euro 500 euro löse geld da habe
ich da habe ich mir damals schon ich weiß ich weiß dass der viel mist erzählt hast du ihm
schon geld gegeben und wieder bekommen ja ich habe ihm schon geld gegeben aber ich habe nicht
also und dann ging es das kam mir schon merkwürdig vor dass das kam mir schon sehr merkwürdig vor
ich weiß dass da viel mist erzählt wenn der tag lang ist und eigentlich fast nichts stimmt von
dem was er erzählt aber ich dachte mir so hey ok wer weiß was dort ist ja und ich habe 500
euro überwiesen und dann hatte die 500 euro ich habe auch gesagt was ist denn hier wie sieht es
denn aus mit polizei und und und mit deutscher botschaft und allem und was auch immer da hat
er sich irgendwelche dinge ausgedacht drum herum zumindest ich habe mir 500 euro überwiesen damals
und irgendwann war er dann wieder in deutschland und dann habe ich rausgefunden was eigentlich
gewesen ist jetzt passt mal auf der wurde nicht entführt der wurde nicht entführt stimmt überhaupt
nicht der ist dort ins krankenhaus gegangen wahrscheinlich weil er irgendwie seine fünf
minuten hatte und wieder gedacht hat er hat was schlimmes denkt öfters dass er was schlimmes
hat und hat er nix der ist ins krankenhaus gegangen dort und wollte abhauen aus dem krankenhaus ohne
zu bezahlen und haben die gesagt nein du bleibst hier bis du bezahlt hast und hatte nicht genug
geld also die wollten nur dass er nicht abhaut aus dem krankenhaus ohne zu bezahlen weil ich
mein ein tourist der dort ins krankenhaus geht abhaut die sehen ihr geld nie wieder also im
prinzip habe ich seine krankenhausrechnung bezahlt warum kann er das nicht so sagen ich habe keine
ahnung weil der immer so ein shit erzählt das hätte sagen ja ich weiß aber das so dinge
sagte der denkt sich immer der denkt sich immer so stories und so ein blödsinn drum herum aus
hätte er das ehrlich gesagt hätte ich bezahlt ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich er hat auch letztens ich habe mit ihm wie gesagt ich habe mit ihm nicht viel
zu tun ich habe mit ihm eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts zu tun da bin ich auch ganz froh
drauf letztens hat er auch wieder angerufen hat gemeint er stirbt gut ich meine wir müssen
wissen der ist jetzt 75 oder so also ich mein ganz so ganz unwahrscheinlich ist es nicht der
raucht auch wie verrückt und lebt auch sonst nicht sonderlich gesund hat er hat mich angerufen hat
gemeint er stirbt und der der krankenwagen kommt gleich vorbei und so was in der richtung
und da habe ich auch gedacht ok was ist los ich meine leute selbst wenn ihr mit eurem
vater nicht so dicke seid ja wenn er euch anruft und sagt es stirbt dann redet ihr trotzdem mit
dem so und dann hat er gefragt ob er ob er bei uns einziehen kann zum sterben und so dinge
was zum teufel ist mit dem schon wieder los da habe ich da habe ich da war ich auch ein paar
tage wirklich schlecht drauf habe ich an fack vielleicht hat er wirklich was aber aber ich
habe mir schon gedacht irgendwas kann da nicht stimmen weil erstens kenne ich ihn und zweitens
hat er viel zu viel zu ja viel zu laut starken eindruck gemacht also viel zu noch viel zu fit
finden eindruck für das dass er gleich sterben wird so und was was ich dann raus bekommen habe
ist er hat wieder ein seiner so hypochonder anfälle gehabt und hat gemeint dass er stirbt
und hat alle verrückt gemacht der hat 1000 mal bei seinem arzt angerufen bei der feuerwehr bei
der polizei so und er war zweimal schon im krankenhaus und das eine mal ist er abgehauen
in der unterhose ist ins taxi gesprungen heim gefahren und das andere mal hat er so die leute
dort beleidigt dass sie ihn nicht mehr weiter behandeln wollen also das muss man sich das muss
man sich mal vorstellen ja und dann hat er bei mir angerufen er stirbt so und zumindest ein paar
tage später war er wieder alles gut dann ist er nicht ist er nicht gestorben er hat ja wirklich
erzählt er hat bloß noch ein quartal zu leben und so was richtig ist richtig ist plötzlich leute
der denkt sich am laufenden bann plötzlich aus so und wisst ihr was eigentlich was eigentlich war
was eigentlich war er war im urlaub in der dominikanischen republik wer hätte sich das
gedacht und als er aus dem flugzeug gestiegen ist in frankfurt ist er irgendwie ausgerutscht
und hingefallen auf den rücken ja er hat eh schon ein bisschen atrose und alles und da konnte
er sich nicht mal richtig bewegen so und daraufhin haben sie ihn ins krankenhaus gebracht so und das
ist das ist der einzig wahre kern dieser geschichte dem ging schlecht im hat alles weh getan ja aber
von aufs maul fallen stirbst du selten das habe ich dann im nachhinein rausgekriegt als er mir
den brief vom krankenhaus ich habe gesagt ich mache gar nix bevor du mir nicht mal vorliest
was das krankenhaus gesagt hat er mit diesem brief vom krankenhaus vorgelesen und da hat
das auch alles alles hin ergeben denkst du er glaubt die geschichten selber ich glaube
mittlerweile dass er die zum gewissen teil glaubt ich glaube da kann sich mittlerweile
on the fly fake sachen ausdenken ohne dass er den unterschied zwischen realität und fake noch
merkt ja und da kam da kam ich so und dann habe ich rausgekriegt dann habe ich rausgekriegt jetzt
jetzt haltet euch mal fest dann habe ich rausgekriegt was der in der karibik gemacht hat ich erzähle
euch nur die kurzfassung von der ganzen sache jetzt ja da gibt es auch viel mehr abgedrehte
details zumindest ich habe rausgekriegt was er in der karibik gemacht hat der hat eine
freundin in der karibik der typ ist 75 ratet mal wie alt seine freundin in der karibik ist leute
ok andere frage andere frage ihr wisst ihr wisst ich bin 38 ihr wisst ich bin 38 ratet mal ob die
freundin von ihm jünger ist oder älter als ich wie gesagt der ist 75 75 jünger ja ja ja ja
volljährig schon da muss ich keine gedanken drüber machen das und das schon jünger richtig die ist
26 das könnte fast fast nicht ganz nicht ganz ok aber es könnte fast meine tochter sein nicht
wirklich ganz aber naja eben ist meine tochter werde irgendwie wenn ich mich wenn ich mich super
beeilt hätte irgendwie 20 oder so aber die ist die 26 so und jetzt und jetzt kommt und jetzt
kommt jetzt jetzt kommt der hit ist jetzt kommt der hit also er bildet sich ja irgendwie ein dass
sie ihn alle furcht furchtbar furchtbar geil finden und er voller voller krasser hecht ist
und so weil weil die auch im prinzip weil die weil die auch im prinzip immer nur darauf gewartet
haben dass 75 jährige rentner aus deutschland sie jetzt beglückt zumindest ich gehe davon aus dass
das eine masche ist der kennt ja über facebook und ich vermute dass es eine masche ist die schreiben
rentner aus deutschland über facebook an und machen den schöne augen einfach um geld abzugreifen ich
glaube das ist der das ist das geschäftsmodell also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass eine
26 hat mir ein follow gezeigt 26 jährige karibik dominikanische republik erinn also eine 26 jährige
junge recht hübsche 26 jährige aus der karibik auf den 75 jährigen rentner in deutschland steht
und das geschäftsmodell wird tatsächlich sein weil er hat auch erzählt es haben sich noch mehr
bei ihm gemeldet das wird ein geschäftsmodell sein die suchen sich auf facebook alte rentner
machen den schöne augen und greifen da geld ab gehe ich ganz stark von aus letztendlich ist das
in irgendeiner art und weise ja auch ok ich meine es wissen ja irgendwo alle seiten worauf sie sich
einlassen wobei ich mir bei ihm nicht so sicher bin ob der ist bei vollem bewusstsein ich glaube
nur dass er sich das bisschen schöner redet als es ist also ich glaube nicht dass er ich denke
schon dass er weiß dass es irgendwie scam ist aber naja wo kriegst du so billig 26 jährige also bei
dem naja zumindest ist er jetzt wieder in deutschland nachdem er da von seiner 26 jährigen
freundin in der karibik zurückgekommen ist 26 75 alle das ist das in 50 da ist 50 jahre das
muss man sich mal auf der zunge sinken 50 jahre älter 50 jahre ja zumindest haben sie ihn jetzt
gescampt und sein konto wurde wurde leer geräumt mit irgendeiner fake überweisung aus der karibik
wahrscheinlich haben sie dort irgendwo seine unterschrift geklaut und haben eine überweisung
bei der bank eingereicht oder so und jetzt haben sie sein konto mit fake überweisung leer geräumt
und jetzt hat die bank sein konto gefriest und ermittelt da irgendwie wegen betrug gegen unbekannt
ich war keine manch andere manch manch andere fangen an mit mit 75 modelleisenbahnen zu bauen
und er macht nur stress überall wieder mann ich glaube das steht immer noch auf die ja ich glaube
nicht dass er das mitten verbindung bringt dass die dahinter stecken könnte keine ahnung hatte
nicht früher selbst andere beschissen doch hat er hatte er hat früher auch gerne alt ältere
leute beschissen mit mit mit nem scam was heute eins zu eins noch genauso funktionieren würde
wahrscheinlich früher auch gerne ältere beschissen ja also insofern leute ich sag euch das ist echt
nicht normal das ist wirklich nicht normal ja und jetzt warum ich eigentlich dazu komme ich
habe ja gesagt der rückt immer nur an wenn er geld will und jetzt nachdem sie sein konto
eingefroren haben hat er sich natürlich wieder bei mir gemeldet und hat gefragt kannst du mir
nicht ein bisschen geld in umschlag stecken und schicken weil mein konto ist doch eingefroren
und ich habe ihm kein geld geschickt und ich habe auch nicht vor ihm geld zu schicken
sitzt er noch in der karibik ne ne ne ne da ist wieder ist wieder daheim der ist wieder daheim
lebt er in einem heim nein der lebt in einer eigenen wohnung irgendwo in offenbach oder so
ist das wie zahlt er mir von der rente bezahlt er miete der kriegt gar nicht so wenig rente
deswegen reicht ja wahrscheinlich auch für miete plus geschenke an seine freundin ich
war in irgendeinem grund muss es haben dass sie das machen ja und das kann eigentlich nur geld
sein wenn konto gefriest ja wahrscheinlich ist es nicht so lang gefriest keine ahnung ist mir auch
egal ist nicht mein problem der manövriert sich immer wieder selbst in so scheiß situationen
ja ja ursprünglich dachte ich mal an first person shooter falls noch jemand fps rusher kennt den
habe ich damals gerne geguckt aber schon seit langem eher für frames per second weil das in
weil das eben auch mit max besser zusammenpasst ja jetzt habe ich ein bisschen ein bisschen
paar persönliche sachen erzählt aber ich soll ich sage euch das ist echt nicht so lustig wie sich
es anhört das ist eigentlich eher nervig und abfack
doch doch das ist ja das ist ja das fatale daran warum es eigentlich besser wissen müsste
der hat früher auf sehr ähnliche masche auch ältere leute beschissen ok letzte
letzte story zwei minuten erzähle ich euch auch noch weil er passt passt jetzt einfach zu gut
dabei der hatte früher auch einen scam business in frankfurt der hatte früher so eine so eine das
war ja noch pre internet und sowas das müsste so in den 80 jahren oder so gewesen sei 80 jahr 90
jahr der hatte eine partnervermittlung in frankfurt und die masche dort bei ihm war
die leute halt super teure verdräge unterschreiben lassen aber damit die das gemacht haben und weiter
beiträge bezahlt haben musste er ja so tun als würde er denen leute vermitteln sie hatten
allerdings nie das ziel wirklich leute zu vermitteln so und was sie jetzt gemacht haben ist die hatten
sich spezialisiert auf alleinstehende ältere frauen und die haben dann die hatte halt beschwätzt und
die haben dann einen super teuren mitgliedervertrag bei seiner partnervermittlung abgeschlossen und
dass sie nicht kündigen beziehungsweise nicht aufhören zu bezahlen hatte er so vier fünf
männer halt sehr schicke eloquente und und hübsche männer wo halt frauen drauf stehen ja hat er so
vier fünf männer und die hat er zu allen heim geschickt so als mögliche partnervermittlung
kandidaten also die haben das waren immer die gleichen vier fünf die er da hatte und die hatte
halt dann immer reih um zu den zu den ganzen mädels heim zu den älteren damen heim geschickt
und hat die ihnen schöne augen machen lassen nur damit die dann quasi weiter mitgliedsbeiträge
bezahlen und das ging dann so weit dass er irgendwann vor gericht gelandet ist also mein
vater war mal man kann nicht sagen dass er im knast war er war in untersuchungshaft also der
hat schon ein bisschen übertrieben mit seinem scam und das lief dann so weit dass er das er vor
gericht gelandet ist aber er wurde freigesprochen was den scam angeht und warum wurde er freigesprochen
aber wohlgemerkt was den scam angeht kommt geht noch weiter waren deine elterner noch zusammen
also am anfang schon aber als das mit gericht und so war nicht mehr zumindest
der war dann vor gericht und er wurde freigesprochen von diesen betrugs vorwürfen
warum näher weil die leute ja absichtlich freiwillig unterschrieben haben es hatte ja
keiner es hatte ja keiner irgendwie gezwungen dazu das zu unterschreiben und den vertrag den
die unterschrieben haben der muss wohl so krass einseitig gewesen sein dass der richter wohl
einen der der geschädigten gefragt hat so nach dem motto formüller warum haben sie das denn
unterschrieben also das muss wohl so einseitig gewesen sein dass es keiner wirklich verstanden
hat wie die das unterschreiben können gut wahrscheinlich weil es zwei stunden beschwätzt
hat dass es das beste das beste vertrag ist aller aller zeit also zumindest er wurde zumindest
er wurde freigesprochen was diese scam vorwürfe anging also da kann man ihm wohl rein rechtlich
gesehen nix vorwerfen aber hat ältere leute gescannt früher was witzig ist wenn er sich
lässt aber wo sie nicht freigesprochen haben ist steuerhinterziehung er hat natürlich von
seinen einnahmen die er da erzielt hat nicht genug steuern bezahlt und das verstehen sie
keinen spaß das kam raus durch dieses ganze durch diese ganze scam taktik wo sie sich dann diese
firma und alles bisschen genauer angesehen haben und da ist ihnen aufgefallen der typ
scam nicht nur leute der bezahlt auch zu wenig steuern und das systematisch und da wurde er
verknackt also nicht wirklich verknackt dass er muss er musste nicht ins gefängnis er war nur
also wie gesagt er war irgendwie ein halbes jahr oder so in untersuchungshaft es hat eine
bewerbungsstrafe oder so gekriegt und musste halt musste halt irgendwie strafe bezahlen und hatte
dann auch irgendwie paar jahre berufsverbot in dieser branche uns war richtig relativ hartes
urteil damals und seitdem hat er auch keine soll man sagen kein nicht mal die füße wirklich auf
den boden gekriegt so business technisch ja also ganz ehrlich mit dem finanzamt solltest du dich
besser nicht anlegen deswegen bin ich persönlich auch super korrekt was steuern angeht also ich
habe nicht ohne grund seit ich angefangen habe mit youtube und twitch ein steuerberater
der das der das macht ich wir wurden auch schon wir ja ich wurde auch schon mal überprüft vom
finanzamt bei dem also alles in ordnung ich bin da ich bin da super pingelig weil ich halt mit
gekriegt habe gut bei ihm war es ja auch noch vorsätzlich absichtlich nix gemacht ja aber
leute können mir glauben wenn ihr es bei eurem vater mitgekriegt habt dass euer vater mal im
knast gesessen hat wegen steuerhinterziehung in untersuchungshaft wegen steuerhinterziehung
da habt ihr selbst ein anderes verhältnis dazu und denkt euch ok ich mach super korrekt wenn
ihr das mitgekriegt habt ok lange rede kurzer sinn mein vater hat leute gescampt
gut so wir sind übrigens ursprünglich auf diese ganze geschichte kommen lohnt sich die
viertageswoche und ja ich bin der meinung die viertageswoche lohnt sich für fast alle die
meisten können sich leisten viele natürlich auch nicht aber ich denke die meisten können sich
leisten und es bringt mal gucken was er sagt ich habe das video nicht geguckt
gar nicht gar nicht der war nur in untersuchungshaft der kam nicht in knast
da wurde da wurde freigesprochen was dieses die bedrugsvorwürfe anging aber wegen steuerhinterziehung
haben sie ihn muss geldstrafe bezahlen weiß nicht was man da sonst noch so kriegt und er
hatte irgendwie fünf jahre oder so für diese branche berufsverbot was was wenn man sich das
anguckt aus der heutigen sicht beziehungsweise auch um die menge wo es da ging eigentlich ein
ziemlich heftiges urteil gewesen ist paar jahre später war hier csu und kohl und uns steuerhinterziehung
und sonst was und jetzt vor ein paar jahren hat man höhnes und sonst was also da ging es ja um
viel viel viel viel größere summen das war er hatte pech das war zur falschen zeit da wurde das
viel härter noch bestraft aber selbst schuld meine hätte ich machen müssen also ich finde so
im nachhinein wenn man das heute mal vergleicht mit wie klimpflig dass das oftmals ausgeht bei
leuten die heute das auch in millionenhöhe gemacht haben so viel war das ja bei ihm gar nicht wie
klimpflig das für die ausgeht war das mit dem berufsverbot schon ziemlich hartes urteil weil
er hat danach nie wieder so die füße auch finanziell auf den boden gekriegt ich mein ernsthaft wer also
du hast du hast die möglichkeit du könntest eine weitere du könnt er könnte hätte wieder
versuchen können eigene firma aufzumachen eines unternehmen zu kunden aber ganz im ernst ja ja da
ist schon lange nee nee damals damals das ist jetzt 75 damals nicht da hat das denke ich schon
relativ clever gemacht ja ja da ist schon lange wieder raus so und was wollte ich jetzt sagen
ja der hat es paar mal versucht firma zu firma zu gründen aber naja mit mit der
geschichte mit mit der historie ja findest du schwierige leute fasst du schwierig bohren
und woanders wirklich anfangen kannst du ja auch nicht weil wer nimmt dich wenn wenn die dich schon
einmal wegen wenn du schon wegen betrug vor gericht warst und vor allem wegen steuerhinterziehung also
der wurde wegen steuerhinterziehung betrug freigesprochen aber steuerhinterziehung verurteilt den
nimmt ja dann auch so ohne weiteres keiner in so einem bereich mehr würdet ihr jemand einstellen
außer ihr seid irgendwie zwielichtiger finanz finanz coach auf telegramm dann ist es wahrscheinlich
sogar beste beste werbung für den beruf dass du den machen kannst aber würdet ihr in einer
seriösen firma so aus der ähnlichen branche wo es auch ums verkaufen geht von irgendwelche
dingern würdet ihr jemand einstellen der wegen betrug vor gericht war und wegen steuerhinterziehung
verurteilt wurde eher nicht oder also ich würde es nicht machen auch aus das ist abholt er hat
ja auch den insi modus gezündet da ist ja alles wieder gut also ihr könnt ja voll ausgehen die
meisten wahrscheinlich nicht also gerade diese fünf jahre oder was der hatte berufsverbot das
war wirklich hart der hat auch nie wieder finanziell die die so die was auf die reihe gekriegt der
konnte sich immer nur so ganz knapp noch noch über wasser halten aber trotzdem jetzt kriegt
er mittlerweile recht gut rente naja gut weiter also vier tage woche lohnt sich auf geht's gucken
wir uns mal an was er dazu sagt
der konnte auch was also im leute belabern kenne ich niemand der besser war als mein vater ohne
scheiß da können die ganze die ganzen kommen meine gruppe telegram leute auf youtube die können
das gar nicht also leute beschwätzen konnte mein vater ich kenne keinen der so gut leute
beschwätzen konnte wie er auf geht's also lohnt sich die vier tage woche dann erzähl mal vielleicht
er kommt abends von der arbeit zurück kocht vielleicht noch eine kleinigkeit aber energie
viel viel mehr das bleibt nicht so wirklich meine eigenen träume und ziele dazu gar nicht was sagen
ja das ist mit vier tage woche auch besser aber man glaubt es gar nicht wisst ihr wisst ihr was
tatsächlich wisst ihr was tatsächlich viel bringt dafür homeoffice ihr spart euch nämlich das dumme
super früh aufstehen hinfahren für keine bezahlung quasi für den fahrtweg das zurückfahren den
homeoffice bringt enorm viel und dann wenn ihr zeit habt geht ihr euch eine stunde bewegen
ihr habt ja quasi viel mehr zeit gespart durch das nicht hin und her fahren müssen ja und dann
geht ihr euch mal halbe stunde reicht wenn es besser als gar nichts aber bei mir ist es quasi
fast schon eine stunde eher eineinhalb stunden ist fast schon fast schon regelmäßig dass es
eher über eineinhalb stunden ist am tag ein bisschen bewegen und dann seid ihr obwohl es
blöd klingt ja mehr bewegung müsste man eigentlich mehr kaputt sein allein man ist tatsächlich abends
dann sogar noch fitter ich habe richtig bock abends teilweise noch stream anzumachen ja manchmal
auch nicht manchmal merkt es mir auch an dass ich übelst kaputt bin aber ich habe viel mehr bock
stream anzumachen vielleicht noch ein bisschen mmo mit ein paar leuten zu spielen kreiselkrall
zu machen und ich hänge nicht mal so sehr in den seiten also homeoffice also vier tagewoche plus
homeoffice plus ein bisschen mehr bewegung man ist man ist richtig richtig richtig gut dabei
und ich muss auch mal sagen ich kann es kann sie nur noch mal betonen ich bin mittlerweile 38
ich war ich habe mich noch nie so fit also lange noch nie ist übertrieben aber ich habe mich schon
lange nicht mehr bestimmt bestimmt die letzten 20 jahre nicht mehr naja und letzten 15 jahre
aber die letzten 15 jahre vielleicht 20 jahre war ja mit 18 letzten 15 jahre ich habe mich die
letzten 15 jahre nicht mehr so fit und so wach so fit und gesund gefühlt wie aktuell und ich
führe das darauf zurück dass tägliche bewegung wirklich nicht verkehrt ist ich wusste das zwar
schon immer aber es ist ein unterschied zwischen wissen und machen
ok also was sagt er zu vier tage woche er kommt abends von der arbeit zurück kocht vielleicht
noch eine kleinigkeit aber energie viel viel mehr das bleibt nicht so wirklich meine eigenen träume
und ziele jetzt zu verwirklichen dafür bin ich irgendwie viel zu erschöpft wie ich dem trott
damit einer vier tage woche entkommen konnte und wie mich das eigentlich produktiv dem trott
einer vier tage woche eine fünf tage woche trinkst du kaffee nicht viel ich bin kein
kein notorischer kaffee trinker ich trinke entweder gar kein kaffee oder wenn überhaupt
nach dem mittagessen mal irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen süß kram und kaffee oder sowas aber
ansonsten zu gut wie gar nicht zeigen die vier tage woche ist auch immer wieder im gespräch
letztendlich existieren da zwei bekannte modelle entweder du arbeitest zehn stunden am tag dafür
dann aber halt auch nur die vier tage in der woche oder du arbeitest nur 32 stunden in der woche
verzichtest dafür aber auf 20 prozent also fürs wohlbefinden ist das hier definitiv die bessere
variante das da oben ist wahrscheinlich aber auch für alle die geldprobleme haben wirklich eine
alternative weil ob du jetzt zwei stunden länger da am tag rumgammelt oder nicht ist für manche
vielleicht gar kein gar kein großartiges ding dafür ein tag mehr frei erholsamer und für das
allgemeine wohlbefinden besser ist aber trotzdem da unten
ja zumal es ist gar keine zehn stunden unbedingt sein müssen sondern
es ja durchaus auch weniger sein können wenn du keine acht stunden am tag hast
also ich persönlich wenn man es finanziell sich leisten kann ist das hier auf jeden fall das
bessere modell ihr macht euch die vier tage nicht fertig weil realistisch betrachtet muss man ja auch
sagen niemand genau das tomox genau das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen niemand kann sich so lang am
stück konzentrieren auch schon keine acht stunden das heißt die zehn stunden ist ja mehr oder
weniger zeit absetzen ja ja kann man sich vielleicht überlegen in kombination mit
homeoffice möglichkeit wenn man sich jeweils vielleicht eine stunde fahrzeit spart am tag
dann kann das durchaus auch so attraktiv sein das zu machen eins bis zwei stunden
fahrzeit spart also ansonsten würde ich das hier unten aber definitiv bevorzugen
eines gehaltes gut beide modelle erfreuen sich bei arbeitnehmern auf jeden fall großer beliebtheit
einige studien oder experimente haben dann auch gezeigt dass sich die produktivität nicht
verringert na gut wisst ihr warum sich die produktivität nicht verringert ich rate das
jetzt einfach mal ohne dies hier gelesen zu haben weil von den acht stunden am tag die
leute in nur vier stunden ordentlich schaffen können und ob die leute jetzt vier stunden
ordentlich schaffen und vier stunden kram drumherum machen oder vier stunden ordentlich schaffen und
sechs stunden kram drumherum machen ist egal dabei auch egal für welches modell du dich
entscheidest denn das haben beide gemeinsam du hast einen weiteren freien tag in der woche
das ist auch noch auf montag oder freitag dann sogar ein drei tage ich erkennt mich ich arbeite
montags nicht wochenende was ich persönlich wirklich sehr zu wertschätzen ist es auch die
möglichkeit sich während des freien tags selbst zu verwirklichen hat mich fasziniert nachdem ich
also von dem konzept gehört hatte stand für mich fest ich will das machen doch da kam auch schon
die ersten probleme auf erlaubt mein arbeitgeber mir das will ich dazu kann ich nur sagen der
arbeitgeber kann so ohne weiteres da gar nichts dagegen sagen also wenn ihr sagen wenn ihr wenn
ihr zu eurem zu eurer personalabteilung geht und sagt ich möchte teilzeit arbeiten ihr müsst ja
nicht sagen ich will vier tage woche aber teilzeit wollt ihr arbeiten da können die eigentlich gar
nichts dagegen sagen die können die könnten höchsten sagen ok das geht aktuell nicht weil
betriebliche gründe dagegen sprechen oder solche geschichten aber selbst dann sind sie eigentlich
verpflichtet diese hinderungsgründe in zukunft abzustellen denn du darfst muss dann zwar ein
halbes jahr warten bis du ihn wieder auf den sack gehen darfst aber so so pauschal ablehnen
ist da gar nicht also in der regel werden sie es dir genehmigen und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
finde nicht dass ich in vier tagen so viel weniger hinbekomme wie in fünf tagen
stunden am tag arbeiten oder komme ich überhaupt mit weniger gehalt aus was sagt das überhaupt
über mein stresslevel aus wenn ich in vier tagen auf einmal die ganze arbeit schaffen soll kann ich
dann überhaupt noch eine karriere erreichen leider mag es schon an den ersten punkten für die meisten
scheitern denn entweder erlaubt der arbeitgeber einem nicht dass man eine vier tage woche anfängt
oder man benötigt doch das volle gehalt ich hatte glück als software entwickler schon relativ gut
zu verdienen und damals hatte mich die lifestyle inflation auch noch nicht ganz erreicht für mich
dann aber auch relativ schnell fest ist es nicht die 10 die was die was hat ihn erreicht hatte mich
die lifestyle inflation die lifestyle inflation also sprich dass das leben an sich einfach nur
teurer geworden ist oder wie oder was ist die lifestyle inflation oder will er sich nur noch
teure sachen kaufen auch noch nicht ganz erreicht für mich dann aber auch relativ schnell fest dass
es nicht die zehn stunden tage werden sollen ich finde acht stunden können extrem anstrengend sein
und zwei noch on top und gerne ich wurde es dann also die 32 stunden weniger gehalten sehr gute
entscheidung sagen dass es bei mir konstant geblieben ist entweder hatte ich vorher schon
genügend stress dass ich jetzt gar keinen unterschied merke weil es sowieso noch so stressig
ist oder ich hatte vorher überhaupt nicht allzu viel stress und es ist lifestyle inflation hat
mich auch erreicht ich habe einen ipad pro bestellt 1400 die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht
aber ähnlich geblieben wobei schon realisiere dass ich manchmal mehr geschafft hätte hätte
ich einen extra tag gehabt zum letzten punkt muss ich dann sagen es kommt drauf an wie du
deinen freien tag verwendest wenn du den ganzen tag nur auf youtube oder social media bist kann
es nach nein nein nein nein wer würde denn sowas machen wer würde seinen ganzen tag auf youtube
und social media verbringen wenn du dann den ganzen tag nur auf youtube oder social media nein
nein 1400 ja bist kann es nach klar sein jetzt muss ich aber mal ehrlich sein das erste jahr
über habe ich das auch so gemacht und je nachdem was dein ziel ist ist es auch vollkommen in
ordnung nutzt du die zeit jedoch vollkommen andere fähigkeiten zu erlernen oder deine jetzigen
fähigkeiten zu verbessern mit irgendwelchen das mache ich aber auch abends auch so aber es ist
cool dass man montags noch einen weiteren tag dafür hat das ist sehr praktisch und das wochenende
obwohl es nur ein tag länger ist kommt einem doppelt so lange vor obwohl es nur ein tag ist
dass es lohnt sich ich kann es immer nur wieder betonen ich habe auch schon ein eigenes video
zu gemacht dass teilzeit arbeiten so die beste entscheidung war die ich je getroffen habe was
arbeitsmäßig angeht tja vielleicht vielleicht wird diese entscheidung allerdings noch übertroffen
durch dass ich mich jetzt für neuen arbeitgeber entschieden habe weil es wurde wirklich mal zeit
ich sehe das jetzt jede woche wieder wie sehr es da den wie sehr es da berg berg abgeht und wie
sehr es da verkackt wird und es hängt jetzt nur davon ab ob es wirklich eine gute entscheidung
war ob der neue so viel besser ist sieht alles bisher danach aus aber wenn ich nicht mal mindestens
ein halbes jahr vor ort mir angeguckt habe kann ich das nicht einschätzen richtig andere
fähigkeiten zu erlernen erbsenraum deswegen würde ich den freien tag nie auf freitag legen weil
freitags sind also man muss ja gucken geld und so ist ja egal an welchem tag du freinimmst man muss
es aber so planen dass du dein maximum rausholen kannst und freitag ist kein guter tag für einen
freien tag weil freitags die meisten leute im kopf schon im wochenende sind und in vielen
unternehmen freitags gar nicht so viel passiert das heißt der beste tag finde ich auch der beste
tag ist montag weil montag ist direkt am wochenende dran da haben die geschäfte schon wieder auf und
alles ist gut und montag haben auch ganz viele leute so richtig tatendrang weil sie aus dem
wochenende kommen und gehen hier auf den sack montag ist für einen freien tag mit abstand das
beste ja ist so beste fähigkeiten zu verbessern mit irgendwelchen projekten zum beispiel die dich
mehr intrinsisch motivieren dann kann es tatsächlich sein dass du attraktiver auf dem
arbeitsmarkt bist das ist jetzt also hauptsächlich deswegen bastel ich ja auch relativ viel
kubernetes stellts in letzter zeit
vergiss nicht du brauchst nur noch vier tage urlaub und eine wache urlaub zu machen das ist
richtig aber du kriegst auch weniger urlaub wenn du teilzeit arbeitest das nimmt sich jetzt nicht so
wirklich viel wie es auszuprobieren mich irgendwie selbst zu verwirklichen und an meinen zielen und
träumen zu arbeiten momentan benutze ich den freien tag dazu an diesen youtube videos hier zu
arbeiten die zeit auf abonnieren zu drücken die lasse ich dir jetzt würde ich machen ich bin
nicht eingeloggt der erste vorteil ist also ganz eindeutig wenn du mehr zeit hast hast du auch
mehr möglichkeiten dich selbst zu verwirklichen einerseits man hat keine zeit man nimmt sich
zeit zwar zu aber andererseits ist es auch deutlich einfacher sich mehr zeit zu nehmen wenn man mehr
zeit hat die weiteren ja das stimmt woche sind auch eindeutig wie viel urlaubstage hast du
demnächst ist es gleiche wie jetzt klar nee nee ich glaube wir haben sogar zwei tage mehr jetzt
glaube ich habe 26 tage jetzt also dann mit vier tage woche glaube ich glaube ich habe 26 tage
ich bin deutlich ausgeglichener zweitens ich bin auch deutlich glücklicher weil ich an meinen
träumen arbeiten kann drittens bin ich produktiver und kreativer lachow so ist es hirtens habe ich
ein deutlich besseres zeitmanagement genau das zeitmanagement kannst du bei mir vergessen aber
dass die zwei sachen die am anfang gesagt hat das sage ich ja auch total oft auch eindeutig bei
mir gewesen erstens ja bin deutlich ausgeglichen genau zweitens ich bin auch deutlich glücklicher
weil ich an meinen träumen aber das auch und wacher wacher leute ihr glaubt gar nicht was
es für ein wichtiger faktor ist einfach nur wach zu sein und so durch die welt gehen zu können
anstatt permanent müde weil er 5 45 oder so aufstehen müsst das ist ein riesen unterschied
weiten kann drittens bin ich produktiver und kreativer und viertens habe ich ein
deutlich besseres zeitmanagement und jetzt sagen wir doch einfach mal ehrlich die besten wochen
sind bis jetzt die gewesen die durch einen feiertag nur vier tage lang sind das stimmt
das dumme ist an montag es gibt relativ viele feiertage die leider auf montag fallen aber gut
dann habt ihr halt pech ich habe jetzt deutlich mehr intrinsische motivation projekte anzugehen
und wenn ich diese projekte jetzt angehe dann will ich die auch wirklich voran bringen das bringt
mich dann dazu ein besseres zeitmanagement zu haben weil ich will ja vorankommen und dieses
bessere zeitmanagement das macht mich dann auch gleich produktiver eine klassische win-win
situation also ich kann es jetzt also nur empfehlen sollte es deine finanzielle lage und dein
arbeitgeber zulassen dass du eine vier tage woche anfängst mache es definitiv denn dadurch hast du
deutlich mehr zeit an deinen träumen zu arbeiten oder auch einfach mal mehr zu entspannen dass du
wirst jetzt nur dass eine vier tage woche nicht alle deine stressprobleme lösen kann was du
dagegen machen kannst dass dieses video gucken in diesem video okay wollen wir das auch noch
gucken das war so kurz das video das gucken wir das gucken wir uns auch noch an jetzt kommen wir
auch noch an
wie bist du eigentlich in kubernetes eingestiegen immer wenn ich was na gut der einstieg war mehr
oder weniger gezwungen weil wir auf der arbeit managt kubernetes in azure verwenden also da
muss man sich zwangsläufig damit mal auseinandersetzen wie erstellt man in die manifest
deployment also ein deployment in einem manifest weil die jammel dateien heißt ja manifest in
kubernetes und da drinne macht man dann so was wie in den deployment da muss man sich zwangsläufig ein
bisschen mit beschäftigen ich muss sagen da wir den managen kubernetes verwenden und ich auch mit
dem managen des managen kubernetes nicht so viel zu tun habe habe ich jetzt die letzten zwei drei
wochen angefangen mich etwas intensiver mal mit den grundlagen von kubernetes auseinanderzusetzen
also mal einen eigenen klasse betreiben gucken wie die pleut man am besten anwendungen drauf wie
macht man das mit zertifikaten wie macht man das mit geht ob es auch so ein komisches wort was
sie sich da ausgedacht haben also wie sollte man dafür dass eben der config stand und der
cluster stand in sync sind das ist ja im prinzip das worum es geht wie skaliert man pots und
solche geschichten das habe ich mir jetzt erst vor drei wochen also angefangen wirklich mal
alles so die grundlagen wo man sich wenn man den cluster zur verfügung gestellt kriegt gar nicht
drum kümmern muss mich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen alles ist tatsächlich wie du sagst
es ist ein absolut bodenloses fass vom prinzip her von den bild in möglichkeiten ist das in
kubernetes relativ überschaubar ja du kannst wenn du mal einen ingress deployed hast wenn du
einen service angelegt hast und dann ein deployment gemacht hast für ein paar pots dann war es ja
mehr oder weniger schon aber dass alles was da drumherum dranhängt ist ein fass ohne boden es
gibt hunderte tools third party geschichten möglichkeiten manifest zu erstellen es ist es
ist ein fass ohne boden halt durch das gesamt durch das gesamte ökosystem wurde dich dann auch ein
bisschen mit ausländer setzen muss gar nicht so sehr jetzt so die eingebauten deployment sachen
in kubernetes das hat man relativ schnell drin aber alles drumherum ist ein riesen riesen fass
ja ne das hast du schon recht würde ich auch nicht machen ich würde wahrscheinlich nie auf
die idee kommen ich ich miete mir jetzt ein paar vms und haue da selbst ein kubernetes cluster
drauf aber selbst wenn man ein managed kubernetes cluster benutzt es schadet auf jeden fall nichts
sich mal damit auseinandergesetzt zu haben wie man so ein ding aufbaut das wissen hier wird
der in zukunft immer helfen selbst wenn du manage kubernetes cluster verwendest und je nachdem wie
managt der ist gibt es ja auch verschiedene ansätze gibt ja welche zum also wenn du bei google
guckst die haben ja die haben ja ihren standard kubernetes managt das ist ja quasi nur die
kubernetes api im endeffekt die control play wie das bei denen immer heißt managt die kümmern sich
um kubernetes updates und sowas aber um so geschichten wie wie sünke ich denn jetzt meine
applikation in meinen cluster und sowas da muss ich mich immer noch selbst kümmern und da ist es
von vorteil wenn man weiß wie der ganze krempel funktioniert ja ums pod skalieren und so muss
ich mich dann auch noch selbst kümmern also ist halt die frage also wie managt das ganze ist wenn
man sich einen github nicht kein github google autopilot kubernetes cluster nimmt dann ist das
wieder was ganz was anderes dann muss ich von kubernetes eigentlich gar keine ahnung haben
weil das bezahlt man ja auch auf pod basis
wir hatten doch gar keine pakete wir hatten doch gar keine package package verlust beim
kubernetes deployment oder oder meinst du ok ok oder meinst du von einer millionen
requests die 40 pakete die verloren gegangen sind ok du meinst die 40 pakete von einer millionen
also die 40 requests von einer millionen requests ok ja gut ok alles klar ok man hätte es vermeiden
können alles ist ich hätte es eigentlich gesagt es ist komplett weinen die 40 requests aber gut
ja gut wenn er wenn es der vip kunde ist dann die 40 requests fällt da hast du pech
du hättest ok was du hättest ein life cycle prestop der den kontent verzwangen schlafen
liegt das du meinst dass die dass die verbindung quasi ordentlich abgebaut werden können die
noch offen sind also quasi die verbindung die reinkommen jetzt sekunde laufen können noch
abgearbeitet werden danach werden alle verbindungen abgebaut und der container bekommt keine neuen
requests mehr und beendet sich erst dann so meinst du das oder also das ist die idee dahinter
das stimmt das ist richtig würde ich generell bei vielen sachen nicht mal machen ich denke
gerade wenn man sich jetzt schon und das haben ja auch viele größere unternehmen jetzt wenn man
sich schon dafür entschieden hat sachen in der cloud zu verwenden ich finde dann kann man auch
richtig all in gehen also wenn man sich schon dafür entschieden hat ich vertraue diesem cloud
anbieter und ich glaube da kriegt das alles hin und wir haben auch keine bedenken was dsgv und
daten und sonst was angeht dann würde ich auch sagen muss man das nicht so nicht so zögerlich
machen dann kann man es auch wirklich ordentlich machen also nicht all in dann kann man es auch
wirklich ordentlich machen und zwar ok man nimmt einen kompletten managed cluster und am besten so
viel managed wie möglich plus man nimmt ein managed postgres plus man nimmt ein managed multi
ingress eingang geschiss plus man nutzt den key store da draus plus man benutzt die container
registry dort weil entweder draußen im cloud anbieter zu dass er den scheiß richtig macht
oder nett und wenn du dem richtig zutraust und dich dafür entschieden hast dass du es machen
kannst dann würde ich auch den kram komplett benutzen und weil ansonsten hast du das das schlechte
aus zwei welten dann hast du so einen den minimalen managed cluster muss trotzdem noch alles selber
machen also wenn schon dann richtig beispielsweise würde ich auch nie auf die idee kommen mir also
nicht mehr nicht mehr ich bin ja eh nicht der große datenbank hält was das angeht ich würde
nie auf die idee kommen zu sagen wir nehmen jetzt so ein standard kubernetes managed cluster und
betreiben da drin eine eigene postgres datenbank da hätte ich viel zu viel schiss dass der kram
manchmal nicht funktioniert nicht ich wüsste was ich dagegen machen kann da nehme ich einfach
bei google managed rrcp ne wie auch immer das heißt rd db ne doch cloud sql cloud sql heißt
ja dann nehme ich einfach so was hier und fertig
zeige ich mal ja paste bin kann man das aufmachen container engine x bla bla bla readiness probe
tcp so tcp so ah ja ok life cycle pre stop exak also ich vermute mal der sinn dahinter ist dass der
container keine neuen requests mehr bekommt ab dem stoppt zeitpunkt der container aber noch
ein bisschen weiter läuft dementsprechend die requests sie noch bekommen hat bevor das service
mitbekommen hat der pot geht down noch verarbeiten kann verbindung die offen sind quasi abbauen kann
keine neuen mehr bekommen sich dann beendet ich glaube das ist eigentlich eine coole sache das
das hat was das hat was das probieren wir probieren das nächste mal aus
das das probieren wir das nächste mal aus hier wo haben wir denn hier unser kubanitas
unser kubanitas to do ja ich kopiere mal das mal rein dass du es nicht vergessen
der hintergrund man stehen hier bester
ja das ist bei beim standards beim standards google kubanitas managed cluster ist das auch
so da ist nur quasi die kubanitas api also diese kubanitas wie heißt man control also das
kubanitas selbst ist dort managed nix weiteres also die machen upgrades in einem in einem
downtime window was du anlegen kannst die haben ein paar hilfen ja die haben ein paar hilfen so
für skalierung und sowas ein bisschen aber groß und ganz muss du dort auch alles mehr oder weniger
machen das ist super mario ball musik
das ist auch das was ich auch gerade gesagt habe ja
ja ok so was gucken wir uns jetzt wir kommen wir gucken uns wir gucken uns noch das nächste video
von ihm an das ging jetzt ja plus drei minuten drei tips für mehr erfolgt moment ist das das
video wo ich schon was drauf geantwortet habe ich bin das haben wir schon gesehen das haben wir
schon gesehen das haben wir schon gesehen lull dann ich da gucken wir das da gucken wir das jetzt
nicht ok was hat was haben wir denn sonst noch acht nervige arbeiten die euch chat gpt abnehmen
kann wisst ihr was das einzige ist wofür ich chat gpt manchmal so als inspiration verwendet das
ist youtube titel videotitel ich benutze ich habe noch nie ein titel eins zu eins von chat gpt
verwendet aber so ein bisschen als inspiration finde ich das für für klickbare titel ganz gut
ok kann das video schon mal aufmachen
das da meinst du power tips volume eins was hat er jetzt nicht jetzt nicht
ok acht nervige arbeiten die euch chat gpt abnehmen kann ok auf geht's jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
rollt er gleich wieder auf seinem stuhl ins bild also diese videos mit diesem quatsch
versprechen habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gesehen überall euer freundlicher nachbar mir geht das
seit anfang an von chat gpt auf youtube auf den sack es gibt die gleiche art videos teilweise
jetzt schon seit drei monaten in folge und die haben ich schon nach der ersten woche gelangweilt
youtube channel ct 300 macht bei diesem clickbait mist aber natürlich nicht mit sondern zeigt euch
ganz konkrete sachen die ihr mit chat gpt machen können nämlich acht oft nervige aufgaben die
chat gpt für euch im alltag erledigen kann reich werdet ihr damit natürlich nicht aber dafür habt
ihr mehr zeit für dinge die euch mehr spaß machen zum beispiel fahrrad fahren mmo kreisel
dieses video wird gesponsert von nord vpn mit nord vpn kann man sich gegen viele cybergefahren
schützen zum beispiel gegen man in the middle gerade kostenlose hast du einen hast hast du
einen link zu dem stream in dem du die archiv vm aufgesetzt hast nee aber das kannst du dir
selbst raussuchen huppst da nicht du kannst ins archiv gehen und das suchen
die suche kaputt
ich glaube die suche ist gerade kaputt jetzt geht's ok was auch immer
ich glaube diese hat gerade einen kleinen bug das archiv
normalerweise sollte man nach arch suchen können
ist das archiv open source hier desktop customise arch by the way hier so diese
diese diese streams hier müssten sein wobei man sagen muss du musst gar nicht so viel
gucken im stream du kannst einfach auf mein github gehen du gehst auf mein github und dann
auf dot files warum auch immer es angeblich python ist ok ah und da hast du alles drinne
ja da hast du die die die shell ist in its wimmer z get konfig und hier den ganzen anderen
krempel drinne kannst du dir eigentlich raussuchen was du was du brauchst
jetzt ok soll ich mal gucken ob es geht wie agiler das schon wieder mitten im stream gefixt
hat er schief jetzt geht's wieder
das ist aber das stream von vor
von vor drei jahren oder
ne da haben wir auch schon mal was gemacht
ok keine ahnung
so
ne dann erzähl mal was vpn
mittlerweile eigentlich weniger es ist ja auch zum glück schon wieder
ein bisschen abgeflacht mich haben die videos nach einer woche schon gelangweilt
auswirkungen haben werden das können wir uns mittlerweile wohl alle denken da ist es auch
gar nicht so überraschend dass die auswirkungen von chat gbt und zum beispiel den ganzen bild
generierungs tools sehr emotional diskutiert werden einige leute haben panik irgendwann ihren
job zu verlieren manche haben sicherheitsbedenken andere machen sich über fehler lustig wieder
andere sind einfach nur irritiert wenn man sich so anschaut was die vermeintlich schlaue neue
bing suche so fabriziert aber das alles ist zwar eine wichtige diskussion nur ist die technik jetzt
nun mal da für alle benutzbar und deshalb dachte ich dass wir uns mal ganz pragmatisch angucken wo
und wie und ob überhaupt chat gbt euch im alltag helfen kann acht aufgaben habe ich gefunden ich
kann mir aber gut vorstellen dass ihr vielleicht viel bessere sachen wissen deshalb würde ich
wissen ja wisst ihr was ich schon mal mit chat gbt gemacht habe tatsächlich wo man es auch
benutzen kann ich habe mir eine email generieren lassen für gute frage
ich überlege gerade
ich glaube ich habe die email doch nicht abgeschickt ich habe ich habe die email
generieren lassen ich glaube als antwort muss man kurz mein email post vor auf machen ich
habe mir eine antwort generieren lassen und zwar send emails
ja jetzt weiß ich für den elektriker jetzt weiß ich es wieder für den elektriker genau
jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich gecheckt ich habe einen termin beim elektriker also ich bin nicht
beim elektriker elektriker muss zu mir kommen weil ich will unten bei mir im schaltschrank im keller
noch eine steckdose haben ich habe da jetzt einige sachen drinne ich habe da zum beispiel
ein microcontroller zum auslesen oder will ich will ich haben zum auslesen von der stromzähler
ich habe da unten ein netzteil für die tablet stromversorgung und so was will noch eine
steckdose haben und ich habe eine antwort generiert an den elektriker aber die habe ich gar nicht
verschickt ich wollte es mal ausführen mit chat gbt die habe ich gar nicht verschickt für diese
geschichte muss der eigentlich vor unterschreiben wegen festliegt
die kommentare reinschreiben könnte für was ihr gbt wie gesagt ich habe ich habe es einmal
ausprobiert eine mail an elektriker als antwort drauf benutzt und vielleicht auch abonnieren wenn
ihr bock habt würden wir uns freuen also nummer eins urlaubsplan fangen wir mal mit etwas an was
wo jeder von uns kennt reiseplan das reiseziel ist ausgesucht und jetzt muss man sich überlegen
was mache ich da eigentlich die ganze zeit also außer am strand zu liegen gerade bei städte
trips ist chat gbt wirklich hilfreich ich tippe einfach mein reiseziel und die dauer in chat gbt
ein und schon bekomme ich einen plan mit sehenswürdigkeiten und dingen die ich
unternehmen könnte alles schon sortiert und nach tagen aufgeteilt hier beim hannover beispiel
muss ich als hannover super ins brauhaus ernst august das problem ist bei chat gbt bei solchen
antworten es ist durchaus möglich dass es das brauhaus ernst august gar nicht gibt
chat gbt sachen sehen immer super korrekt aus aber sind teilweise einfach glatt gelogen
sagen die großen highlights sind alle dabei und zusätzlich sogar so dinge die nicht in
jedem reiseführer stehen also echt ganz gut aber bei jedem meiner versuche so eine reiseplanung für
hannover zu machen war ein teil kompletter unsinn entweder einfach ausgedacht oder zumindest
in details falsch hier zum beispiel das restaurant 11a gibt es und das ist auch echt nett aber es
befindet sich in einem klitzekleinen einstöckigen häuschen und nicht im listatur den gibt es zwar
auch aber der ist fast eine stunde zu fuß vom restaurant 11a entfernt außerdem kann man in
den listatur auch nicht reingehen also das mit der tollen aussicht ja nee und das thema
gbt erfindet quatsch werde ich für den rest des videos nicht mehr erwähnen das muss man immer mit
bedenken das passiert jederzeit und kann jederzeit passieren und deshalb muss man alle ergebnisse von
gbt immer manuell überprüfen vor allem wenn es um was wirklich wichtiges geht so jetzt aber weiter
beim städtetrip plan natürlich kann ich ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wenn man wirklich nicht
immer perfekt funktionierenden kaut programmiert was ja eigentlich best practices sind wir uns ja
einig einfach keine fehler programmieren dann hast du keine probleme mehr da könnte man vielleicht
gbt fragen ob die einem irgendwie ein bisschen dokumentation schreiben kann
bitten bestimmte attraktionen besonders zu berücksichtigen und ich kann mich jetzt nicht einloggen
moment wir probieren es jetzt mal wir probieren es jetzt mal kurz aus
chat ihr müsst mal kurz ihr müsst mal kurz weg kurz nicht hier wirst mal kurz weg ich logg mich
jetzt mal bei chat gbt ein und dann fragen wir fragen wir die mal kurz was ob das
login ich hoffe ich weiß mein password überhaupt aus dem kopf
japp hat funktioniert
ok hier sind wir wieder
ok wir fragen wir fragen gbt jetzt mal kurz und zwar wir nehmen einfach mal wir nehmen einfach mal
was hier aus aus dem fiat champ da wollte ich jetzt nicht hinklicken add-on
response seht ihr irgendwas sinnvolles nee ja ok nehmen wir mal hier irgendwas
irgendwas raus ok
was macht diese funktionen
ups ja ja ist ja gut was macht diese funktion
nicht wirklich nicht wirklich nicht wirklich ws credentials werden da zwischendurch auch
abgerufen aber das ist nicht sinn und zweck der sache
das stimmt nicht wirklich das stimmt nee gbt 4 kommt irgendwann so im lauf des jahres oder so ok
wie können wir schreiben schreibe eine
jetzt kommt das ganze einfach noch auf englisch ok
wenn man jetzt richtig pro ist könnte man noch in den prompt schreiben und so dafür
naja abisi abisi lang jetzt können wir noch sagen
ja auf jetzt ist ja gut boah das hört ja gar nicht auf ok
maximal fünf zeilen lang
das ist schon mal besser ja das ist schon mal besser
wobei das halt auch total total unspezifisch ist
also das wird jetzt nicht wirklich was bringen aber ausprobiert weiter geht's
das macht gpt auch ganz ohne meckern es sei denn ich frage jetzt zum beispiel nach koffeeshops in
amsterdam dann wird gpt meckerig und weiß mich darauf finden dass amsterdam auch ohne kiffen
sagt irgendwas von illegalen oder unnötigen aktivitäten nur sind koffeeshops in amsterdam
halt legal ok na gut nächstes thema nummer zwei briefe schreiben eine andere etwas nervige
aufgabe die die meisten von uns manchmal haben ist das schreiben von briefen oder mails wenn ich
zum beispiel meine mitgliedschaft im fitnessstudio kündigen möchte kann ich einfach in chat gpt
meine mitgliedsnummer und den namen des studios schreiben und schon habe ich eine fertige und
freundliche kündigung dafür ist es nice ja dafür ist es nice hier würde ich definitiv
nicht anmerken dass die kein mensch geschrieben hat auch im arbeitskontext nimmt einem gpt
unliebsame mails ab zum beispiel wenn man eine konkrete ansage machen will im team dabei aber
möglichst freundlich rüberkommen will und nicht wie so ein polternder meckerhaini schreibe einen
brief an die windows kollegen in dem steht dass sie zukünftig nur noch linux benutzen ach mist
jetzt habe ich schon zugemacht ich wollte chat gpt gerade fragen warum ist warum ist windows so
kacke und linux viel besser zu administrieren schreibe das aus sicht eines windows admins
was ich dabei sehr beeindruckend finde chat gpt formuliert nicht nur die von mir vorgegebenen
dinge sondern bringt sogar von sich aus plausible argumente dafür in dem linux beispiel unter anderem
dass linux kostenlos ist sicherer ist und so weiter und so weiter also wirklich nett und
wirklich zeitsparend nummer drei schule und uni ja also dass man chat gpt natürlich super
benutzen kann um hausarbeiten zu schreiben ist ja klar das war eine der ersten populären
einsatzgebiete das gab dann zuerst ein bisschen panik wie sollen wir jemals über
also
mein ganzer browser ist dead oder mein ganzer browser ist f wie nübbar
so viele tabs vielleicht
schule und uni ja also dass man gpt natürlich super benutzen kann um hausarbeiten zu schreiben
ist ja klar das war eine der ersten populären einsatzgebiete das gab dann zuerst ein bisschen
panik oh nein wie sollen wir jemals überprüfen was eine kai geschrieben hat und was echte
menschen ja und die qualität der gpt ergebnisse wurde auch überprüft hat zum beispiel ein
medizin einstiegsexamen in den usa bestanden und auch eine mba abschlussprüfung nur am bayerischen
abitur ja das hat sich hier gekriegt ist es gescheitert naja inzwischen ist auf jeden fall
die moderne lehrmeinung dass man gpt lieber als hilfsmittel im unterricht einsetzen sollte und
dort fehler und grenzen der technik diskutiert statt es einfach stumpf zu verbieten interessant
finde ich übrigens dass nicht nur schülerinnen und schüler sich mit gpt die hausaufgaben
einfacher machen können sondern auch die lehrkräfte ich weiß von mindestens einem
lehrer der mit gpt schon seinen unterricht vorbereitet hat das geht nämlich auch ebenso
wie meetings oder andere veranstaltungen kann man sehr gut vorbereiten mit gpt einfach ein paar
stichwörter reinhauen zack fällig nummer vier bessere prompt für stable diffusion bekommen der
nächste punkt ist zugegeben etwas spezieller und richtet sich an die illustratoren oder
fotografen unter euch wenn ihr in einem bild generator wie stable diffusion einen bestimmten
look nachstellen wollt also zum beispiel ein bild von einer eule die so aussieht als hätte sie
van goch als selbstportrait gemalt dann müsst ihr das bild nicht selbst beschreiben ihr könnt
das wollte ich auch schon mal fragen gibt mir die visuelle charakteristik von van goch selbstportrait
ist am besten auf englisch weil die bildgeneratoren deutlich besser auf englisch funktionieren ja und
was da rauskommt ist zwar kein richtiger prompt direkt für stable diffusion aber ich kann mir
da die stichworte rausholen also sowas wie bold brushstrokes et cetera und klar man könnte auch
einfach den namen van goch im prompt konkret nennen aber durch den umweg über gpt bekommt man
deutlich mehr stellschrauben an denen man drehen kann also zum beispiel wenn ich das bild nicht
als öl gemälde sondern beispielsweise als aquarelle haben will nummer 5 recherche fast
egal um welches thema es geht ist eine super anlaufstelle um etwas zu recherchieren und einen
ersten eindruck von einem thema zu bekommen wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel etwas über rasenmeer
roboter erfahren möchte dann wäre etwas recherche support das stimmt schon der garten und absolut
keine ahnung was man bei rasenmeer robotern so beachten muss also frage ich einfach mal okay
da würde ich mir da würde ich mir aber lieber in den testvideos auf youtube durchgucken ich keine
ahnung habe aber gut ich meine so für eine grobe übersicht dass es nicht verkehrt punkte die wichtig
sind zum beispiel die maximal mögliche rasenfläche und dazu bekomme ich auch mehr infos wenn ich
genauer nachfrage es geht da zum beispiel um die schnittbreite nach ein wenig externer für
inspiration ist es wirklich gut wie gesagt ich habe mich da auch schon für youtube titel
inspirieren lassen durchaus was dran zu sein und das ist hier auch der punkt einfach eine frage
an chat tpt stellen so ins blaue das ist meistens irgendwie lustig aber in die tiefe kommt man so
nicht ihr solltet also immer auch den kontext eures bisherigen gesprächs nutzen bei der
recherche ist so wie es jetzt ist durchaus praktisch wenn ihr den ersten einblick in
thema sucht und ein paar anhaltspunkte braucht nummer 6 brainstorming aber auch fürs brainstorming
ist ein wirklich gute hilfe denn egal über welches thema ihr euch gedanken macht ihr könnt
das ja das das das habe ich mir auch schon gedacht die haben immer eine gewisse art und weise wie
chat gpt antworten aussehen zumindest ohne ohne irgendwie custom prompt oder sowas die antworten
sind immer die sehen chat gpt mäßig aus ist schwierig zu sagen wie wo haben wir das ja das
fängt dann immer so an wenn du die fragst hier wer ist da wer ist der beste streamer auf twitch
wenn du chat gpt fragst dann fängt chat gpt an immer so mit der frage noch mal so nach dem motto
was wer der beste streamer auf twitch ist kommt auf unterschiedliche kriterien an so das wäre
eine typische chat gpt antwort nur dass sie viel weitergeht wer der beste streamer auf twitch ist
kann irgendwie hängt von verschiedenen kriterien ab da kriterien nummer eins die anzahl der
abonnenten bitte beachte auch dass die anzahl der abonnenten nicht den inhalt des streams
widerspiegelt so bla bla das liest sich so so chat gpt mäßig halt man man erkennt das irgendwie
wenn die leute irgendwie sich custom prompt oder so ausdenken dann wird es natürlich schon wieder
ein bisschen anders aber also diese standard antworten liessen sich so chat gpt like halt
die eingeben und bekommt dann mehr oder weniger brauchbaren text der zb grundlage für ein echtes
brainstorming ist hier genauso die wiederholen am anfang wiederholt die immer noch mal so ein
bisschen anders formuliert die frage weil man kennt das ja oft ist vor allem der erste schritt
der schwierigste und der wird einem dann von chat gpt abgenommen nummer sieben korrektur lesen egal
ob du ein liebesbrief oder ein youtube kommentar oder blog post schreibt kann immer passieren dass
sich irgendwo ein fehler einschleicht und genau deshalb wäre es doch super wenn du ab sofort
jemanden an deiner seite hättest der jeden text von dir noch mal korrektur liest kann chat gpt das
ich habe einfach mal eine fertige meldung von der tagschau genommen und von chat gpt auf stil
rechtschreibung und grammatik prüfen lassen als ergebnis kommt dann etwa sowas hier ja ok
chat gpt konnte keine groben fehler finden aber ein wenig input kommt auch der text könnte besser
werden mit verschiedenen satz strukturen und mehr hintergrundinformationen oder zitaten naja könnte
man bestimmt machen aber bei einer kurzen meldung erwartet auch niemand ein feuerwerk an stil
mit ganz im gegenteil und zitate sind halt sowieso schon drin in diesem fall klingt das feedback von
der k.i. eher nach recht generischen hinweisen aus dem schreibkurs und fun fact wenn ich das
script für die genau dieses video hier unter den gleichen gesichtspunkten checken lasse redet
chat gpt plötzlich englisch das problem haben wir schon öfter gesehen weil sprach k.i. offenbar
oft intern hin und her übersetzen dafür gibt es jetzt detaillierteres inhaltliches feedback nachdem
ich gar nicht gefragt habe so richtig verlässlich scheint es mit dem gegenlesen also nicht zu klappen
zumindest in deutscher sprache ich meine stellt euch mal vor ihr fragt jemand nach feedback zu
einem text und die person redet plötzlich in einer anderen sprache über sachen die ihr gar nicht
wissen wollt da würdet ihr vermutlich in krankenwagen wieso das passiert bei mir im stream doch
regelmäßig ich rede total oft über sachen die ihr gar nicht wissen wolltet und manchmal auch
random englischwörter weil mir die auf deutsch nicht einfallen wichtig ist nur auch hier wenn die
erste antwort gaga ist einfach mehr kontext liefern durch eine weitere nachfrage etwas besser
funktioniert bei längeren texten wenn man mit einzelnen absetzen arbeitet aber eine wirklich
kohärente bewertung bekommt man so natürlich nicht was dafür sehr gut klappt mit gpt sind
einfache textdienstleistungen zum beispiel dann wenn ihr den text umschreiben kürzen oder
verlängern wollt wichtig ist nur dass ihr genau sagt was ihr wollt prompt wie bitte macht diesen
text um 20 wörter kürzer oder bitte schreibt diesen text um in einen akademischen stil oder
übertrage diesen text in knappe stichpunkte mit insgesamt unter 500 wörtern länge oder auch
mach aus diesem text ein seo text und baue das keyword rase mehr in angemessener dichte ein
könnte dann auch durchaus funktionieren je genauer der prompt und je genauer der
vorherige gesprächsverlauf desto besser und zack das ist tatsächlich eine coole sache
texte kürzen oder vielleicht ein bisschen erweitern bisschen umschreiben habe ich
noch nie ausprobiert klingt eigentlich sehr sinnvoll den input den ihr braucht um all
deadline einzuhalten nummer 8 social media marketing und genauso kann man natürlich auch
in anderen bereichen vorgehen zum beispiel im social media marketing da gibt schon länger
ki tools die extra für solche aufgaben optimiert sind zum beispiel jasper dafür muss man allerdings
ziemlich teure abos abschließen und bekommen tool das ja eben in erster linie content erstellt wenn
man als agentur geld damit verdient kann sich das lohnen bei kleinen teams oder freiberuflern ist
das aber eher schwierig wäre doch eigentlich toll wenn unser allrounder chat gbt das direkt
übernehmen könnte also versuchen wir mal das in einen möglichst genauen prompt reinzugießen
darin sagen wir dann was wir genau brauchen was wir damit tun wollen und wie das ganze aussehen
soll zum beispiel so erstelle mir den text für einen werblichen post für einen rasenmeer roboter
den ich auf instagram posten kann bitte erstelle dazu auch eine idee für das visual und das
ergebnis finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht wir haben ohne emojis wichtig passende emojis
hashtags und ja sogar die visual idee ist zwar nicht unvergleichbar klar ich bin jetzt überhaupt
kein marketing experte aber das könnte man vermutlich schon fast so machen als teil einer
größeren kampagne wenn ihr also weniger textliches gold sucht sondern funktionalen stoff braucht dann
kann das schon alles ganz gut funktionieren fazit ja chat gbt kann euch in vielen bereichen schon
wirklich weiterhelfen aber es ist definitiv kein wunderbild wer mit chat gbt arbeiten will muss
chat gbt auch richtig bedienen können und das ist doch eigentlich eine ganz gute chance denn
wer sich jetzt die skills drauf schafft und lernt wie man damit arbeitet muss vielleicht schon viel
weniger angst haben morgen komplett von einem browser tab ersetzt zu werden ja und wenn ihr noch
mehr dazu wissen wollt mittlerweile gibt es sogar webinare rund um die frage wie man ki tools
pragmatisch für die arbeit nutzen kann darunter auch eines von meinen kollegen von der ct
natürlich das ganze klappt manchmal auch wunderbar wenn ihr wirklich kreativen input braucht zum
beispiel ein slogan für meine sensationelle produktidee hier gibt mir einen modernen
griffigen slogan für einen rasenmäher robot der beim mehen mell musik ich gehe jetzt
hätt bänge der rasen schnitt der mätel mehr roboter macht es möglich gar nicht mal so
schlecht das wird uns auf jeden fall in der zukunft weiter begleiten dieses thema und es
wird immer besser werden da bin ich echt gespannt wie sie ein paar jahren aussieht
ein bisschen zu laut also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an was haben wir denn hier noch
schönes oh leute bald ist bald ist pippo fett heim ich schon demnächst
finanzfluss hat ein video zur rente mit 30 rausgebracht ok den gucke ich tatsächlich
manchmal ich weiß nicht wie lang das video ist in diesem video ok mit 35 rente gehen
finanzplanung für 18 ok ich bin jetzt schon über 35 und kann noch nicht in rente gehen
gucken wir uns das ganze mal an zeig mal rente rente mit 35 15 minuten das kann man so angucken
30 jahren in rente genug geld auf der seite liegen haben um nicht mehr arbeiten gehen zu müssen das
ist der traum von vielen menschen hast du geplant früher in rente zu gehen auf jeden fall habe ich
also das habe ich nicht nur geplant das habe ich fest vor auf jeden fall will ich früher in rente
gehen ich arbeite nicht bis 65 kannst du kannst ja abschminken ja oh ich sehe gerade auch das
warum ist das so kacke unter windows
sie ist minimal zu laut ist es so deswegen haben wir das ganze in diesem video einmal
durchgerechnet ok auf geht's stellen wie realistisch oder doch nicht das ganze ist dabei
haben wir uns nicht auf die theorie beschränkt sondern echte praxisbeispiele von menschen aus
messen wir haben uns echte haushaltsbudgets von personen beziehungsweise familien angeschaut und
mal durchgerechnet ob die mit 35 finanziell frei sein können also in rente gehen können das ist
ganz einfach man muss nur in die passende whatsapp gruppe hi mein name ist thomas und
finanzus und heute rechnen wir mal wieder ein bisschen und zwar werden wir einmal konkret für
einige community mitglieder ausrechnen ob sie mit 35 in rente gehen können hierzu haben wir uns von
verschiedenen community mitgliedern einmal die finanz fluss diagramme angeschaut auf unserer
webseite findet ihr ein tool womit ihr ein solches finanz fluss diagramm oder ein senki
chart hier müsst ihr einfach nur eure monatlichen einnahmen und eure monatlichen ausgaben eintragen
und bekommt dann einen solchen chart erstellt diese charts sind bei uns in der community super
beliebt und werden uns auch sehr gerne zur analyse soll ich das mal machen über fluss
rübergeschickt aus mehreren hunderten finanz ich weiß gar nicht was ich für ausgaben habe haben
wir uns mal ein paar interessante für dieses video rausgesucht wenn ihr selbst mal euer budget oder
fluss diagramm erstellen wollt dann schaut gerne mal unten in der video beschreibung dort haben
wir euch den kostenlosen rechner verlinkt besonders interessant für unsere analysen waren vor allem
zwei arten von budgets die erste art sind besonders gut verdienende menschen denn
ein high performer und desto höher ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man mit dem 35 lebensjahr
die rente erreichen kann die zweite kategorie waren community mitglieder die mit einfach
verdienen aber sehr frugal leben das bedeutet ein besonders geringes ausgabenniveau haben und
somit gar nicht so viel zum leben brauchen das stimmt ich gebe kaum was aus das ist zum
beispiel der fall für diesen 22 jährigen konstrukteur aus österreich er verdient rund
2500 euro netto diese angaben sind immer netto angaben denn das ist das was tatsächlich auf eurem
konto ankommt sind die steuern also schon weg und von diesen 2500 euro spart er knapp 1850 euro damit
hat er eine atemberaubende sparquote von 73 prozent ähnlich sieht es für diesen 19jährigen dualen
studenten aus er verdient etwas mehr als 1000 euro und legt davon etwas mehr als 800 euro auf
die seite auch das ist eine sehr stolze sparquote jetzt muss man bei diesen beiden beispiel natürlich
anmerken dass wir sehen dass es hier keine mietzahlungen gibt denn beide wohnen noch bei
ihren eltern und da fällt natürlich ein sehr großer kostenblock raus das ist natürlich eine
ziemlich smarte strategie je länger ihr bei euren eltern wohnen könnt desto länger zögert ihr es
raus selbst miete zahlen zu müssen oder eine kreditrate wenn ihr euch ein haus finanziert
man könnte sich zumindest ein bisschen daran beteiligen er geld auf die seite legen später
bei der berechnung der rente ab 35 jahren haben wir dann allerdings nicht dieselben lebenshaltung
kosten angesetzt denn das wäre ja ein klein bisschen geschummelt man kann nämlich nicht
davon ausgehen dass diese personen ein leben lang bei den eltern wohnen werden und ein leben lang
mit so wenig geld auskommen können deswegen haben wir im späteren verlauf dann angenommen
dass diese personen in zukunft also ab dem 35 lebensjahr 2000 euro monatlich brauchen
wir haben also das rechte budget angesetzt was die leute derzeit ohne scheiß damit würde ich
ohne probleme auskommen zum leben brauchen oder eben die 2000 euro wenn die ausgaben derzeit
extrem niedrig sind wie bei unseren beiden vorherigen beispiel unser konstrukteur lebt
ja derzeit von 662 euro und der duale student sogar gerade mal von 230 in die gruppe der jungen
frugalisten wie ich sie jetzt mal genannt habe rein sich noch zwei weitere menschen ein einmal
ein azubi der ebenfalls noch bei seinen eltern wohnt der 22 jahre alt ist rund 1000 euro verdient
und davon über 800 auf die seite legt und ein 18 jähriger elektriker den netto 2000 euro monat
verdient und 900 euro davon monatlich auf die seite packt hier sehen wir dass er tatsächlich
schon mietausgaben hat das bedeutet man kann hiervon ausgehen dass er nicht mehr bei seinen
eltern wohnt das erklärt auch dass seine sparquote deutlich geringer ist als bei den anderen drei
kandidaten aber mit 45 prozent immer noch extrem hoch das budget des elektrikers haben wir uns
übrigens auf überfluss schon mal genauer angeschaut das video habe ich euch hier oben verlinkt jetzt
wo wir budget und sparrate kennen und wissen wie viele jahre diese personen noch haben bis zum
35 lebensjahr machen wir uns ans werk und rechnen einmal aus wie viel vermögen diese
personen denn brauchen um ab dem 35 lebensjahr davon leben zu können jetzt so eine kleine
beispielrechnung wenn wir beispielsweise davon ausgehen dass wir jeden tausend wenn wenn der
ein irgendwie 26 ist ich meine das in neun jahre bis der 35 ist da kann er noch da kann er zwar
super krass sparen aber ich mein wie soll das funktionieren ok mal zur verfügung haben müssen
da multiplizieren wir diese zahl zunächst einmal mit 12 12.000 euro und dividieren dann diese
zahl mit der sogenannten entnahme rate die wir jetzt mal auf drei prozent angesetzt haben 12.000
euro geteilt durch drei prozent ergebte 400.000 euro das ist also das vermögen was man auf der
seite liegen haben muss um sich monatlich 1000 euro auszahlen zu lassen aber aber aber für aber
für wie lang für wie lang
also wie lange hält das dann das verstehe ich das kapier ich nicht
immer
nehmen wir hier eine entnahmequote von drei prozent an dazu haben wir mal ein ausführliches
video gemacht das habe ich euch unten in der video beschreibung verlinkt grob noch mal
zusammengefasst langfristig gehen wir davon aus dass der kapitalmarkt nach inflation zwischen
fünf und sieben prozent rendite bringt diese renditen schwanken aber und es gibt das sogenannte
rendite reinfolgerisiko aus diesem risiko ergibt sich eine sogenannte pleitewahrscheinlichkeit und
um diese pleitewahrscheinlichkeit also die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich in irgendeinem
szenario auf dem trockenen sitze zu reduzieren schraubt man die entnahmequote deutlich unter
diese fünf bis sieben prozent in unserem fall jetzt mal auf drei prozent manche haben hier
also ich glaube ich habe es verstanden also die rechnen damit dass wenn man 400.000 euro anlegt
quasi man sieben prozent im jahr ja wie soll man sagen sieben prozent von den 400.000 im jahr
quasi plus macht und von das bezahlt man wieder ein und dann nimmt man also davon nimmt man drei
prozent den rest bezahlt man wieder ein so irgendwie
wie auch immer vielleicht argumentieren dass auch drei prozent noch ein bisschen optimistisch
gerechnet ist denn das aufgebaute vermögen muss ja ziemlich lange halten bei einer lebenserwartung
von 85 jahren und einem renteneintritt mit 35 jahren muss das vermögen ja ganze 50 jahre halten
das ist schon eine ziemlich lange zeit jetzt so wir wissen wie viel vermögen wir brauchen
rechnen wir das ganze einmal durch wir sind jetzt einmal von sieben prozent rendite ausgegangen bis
zum erreichen des 35 lebensjahres das heißt die personen fangen jetzt ohne startkapital an ihr
erspartes monatlich auf die seite zu packen bis zu ihrem 35 lebensjahr und wir sind hier
mal davon ausgegangen dass sie mit einer rendite von sieben prozent rechnen können auch an dieser
stelle noch mal renditen können natürlich schwanken es gibt keinerlei garantie also mein world etf
sagt dieses jahr nichts von sieben prozent dass ihr diese sieben prozent erzielen werdet vor allem
da die zeiträume auch verhältnismäßig kurz sind nichts desto trotz blenden wir hier jetzt einmal
das ergebnis ein auf wie viel kapital die entsprechenden personen kommen werden wenn wir
jetzt hier einmal die kapitalertragssteuer nicht mit berücksichtigt da wir davon ausgehen dass
die anteile nicht zwangsläufig direkt verkauft werden sondern erst später bei der verrentung
verkauft werden und hier gelten dann individuelle steuerliche raumbedingungen am besten schneidet
unser österreichischer konstrukteur ab mit etwas mehr als 445.000 euro wenn wir das jetzt einmal
mit drei prozent verrenten also drei prozent hier von jedes jahr entnehmen und das dann auf die
monate verteilen würde er auf eine monatliche verrentung von 1114 ok ok ok ok ok also nur dass
du nicht das jetzt richtig nur dass jetzt richtig richtig kapiere natürlich 22 und bezahlt jetzt
quasi ein bezahlt jetzt im monat 1800 euro ein bis er 35 ist so es wird wahrscheinlich noch ein
bisschen mehr werden dann und dann hat er und dann hat er bis 35 445.000 euro zusammen oder
moment wie wie das denn der hat proben na gut er hat ja na gut ich meine da sind ja schon
18.000 euro im jahr 18.000 euro im jahr und das dann irgendwie mal 13
dann hat er aber bloß 200 aber der moment dann muss noch ok und dann sammelt sich das an durch
sieben prozent jährliche jährliche den ok ok ok ok ja ja alles klar ja ok sein aktuelles
budget also das was er derzeit ausgibt liegt allerdings nur bei 662 euro das bedeutet wenn
er seine kosten konstant halten kann und diese nicht weiter ansteigen dann ist die finanzielle
freiheit mit 35 tatsächlich drin bei ihm dasselbe trifft auf den dualen studenten zu wie auch auf den
azubi der bei seinen eltern wohnt lediglich der elektriker muss hier leider abstriche machen er
würde in unserer theoretischen rechnung auf 333.000 euro vermögen kommen was einer verrentung von 833
euro im monat gleich kommen würde was aber nicht sein aktuell damit kommste halt nicht wirklich hin
also mit 2000 euro vielleicht aber 800 833 euro mein davon kannst du dir in vielen städten
nicht mal eine wohnung leisten bedarf von derzeit 1100 euro deckt rechnen wir einmal ein zweites
szenario durch drei jahre wie was drei jahre was drei jahre drei jahre was
drei jahre ist mal azubi ja gut er kann danach halt ein bisschen mehr einbezahlen ok aber der
jessert der hat ja schon fertig aber du kommst du kommst halt mit 833 euro noch gar nicht großartig
seit 1100 euro deckt rechnen wir einmal ein zweites szenario durch denn wir haben ja eingangs
gesagt dass unsere ersten drei kandidaten noch bei ihren eltern leben und deswegen keine
mietausgaben haben und die mietausgaben in der regel ja so ziemlich das teuerste sind was wir
haben deswegen geben wir modellrechnung nummer 2 und geben wir davon aus dass hier 2000 euro
pro monat benötigt werden in diesem fall schafft es keiner der vier kandidaten mit 35 dieses ziel
zu erreichen was er hierfür benötigen würde wäre ein initialer start booster also ein startkapital
wo das startkapital herkommt ist zunächst einmal unerheblich das geld kann vorher angespart
worden sein aber auch eine erbschaft oder ein lotto gewinn sein hier blenden wir euch mal ein
wann planst du in rente zu gehen wenn ich keinen bock mehr habe startkapital sein müsste bei
unserem österreichischen konstrukteur werden 147.000 euro die er zum start benötigen würde die größte
lücke hat der azubi mit rund einer viertel millionen euro das liegt natürlich daran dass
sein gehalt verhältnismäßig niedrig ist und dementsprechend auch absolut gesehen seine
sparquote das war soweit die frugalisten fraktionen also diejenigen die ein mäßiges
gehalt haben die aber eine extrem hohe sparquote haben schauen wir uns jetzt einmal die andere
fraktion an die sogenannten high earner also leute die wirklich sehr sehr viel geld verdienen und
dabei auch noch ziemlich sparsam sind auch von denen gibt es sehr viele bei uns in der community
wir haben hier einmal exemplarisch vier kandidaten rausgesucht die natürlich alle unter 35 jahre alt
sind ansonsten ist das ziel der finanziellen freiheit mit 35 wird schwierig haben wir einen
researcher der in zürich arbeitet 27 jahre alt ist 8100 euro netto aufs konto ist natürlich
hart das kriege ich ja knapp brutto wenn überhaupt 1100 euro netto mit nach hause nimmt wovon er
wobei das war überlegen das war überlegen auf fünf tage gerechnet
das mal kurz gucken
durch zwölf
ok bei mir sind es ungefähr 9000 wenn man wenn man mit dem ganzen bonus und allem rechne durch
zwölf sind ungefähr 9000 brutto im monat da bleibt er bleibt er nicht so viel übrig ok
keine chance das auf die seite liegt das ist das ist das ist aber gut das sind das sind die
die schweizer ja aktuelles budget immerhin 6000 euro sind also er ist nicht unbedingt ein
frugalist dann haben wir eine 28 jährige führungsperson aus einem dax konzern die
ungefähr 7300 euro netto mit nach hause nimmt und schon mal deutlich frugal moment
warum nimmt die 7000 euro mitteilen wenn sie gehalten nur 4000 euro hat nämlich davon 4000
euro monatlich auf die seite packt dann haben wir ein 32 moment das verstehe ich nicht das
verstehe die hatten gehalt von 4000 sie mann warum hat die dann budget von 7000
ach so die bekommt noch anderweitig ok verstehe ok da muss da muss ich noch youtube und geschiss
bei mir mit rein rechnen auch ja klar na dann ok ok warum monatlich auf die seite packt dann
haben wir einen 32 jährigen familienvater wie viel packt monatlich auf die seite
das habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert dax konzern die ungefähr 7300 euro netto mit nach hause
nimmt und schon mal deutlich frugal erlebt nämlich davon 4000 euro monatlich auf die
seite 4000 euro im monat sparen hast du ordentlich was dann haben wir ein 32 jährigen ich meine das
könnte ich fast auch machen mit meinen nicht vorhandenen ausgaben fast müsste ich müsste
das mal durchrechnen ich müsste dass ich müsste das mal durchrechnen also nicht ganz nicht ganz
auf jeden fall aber wahrscheinlich für ich meine ausgeben tue ich ja so gut wie nix
was die was was die machen sollen ja hat er doch gesagt die legen das an so dass es
ungefähr sieben prozent im jahr gibt da dazu hat er jetzt nichts speziell das gesagt
familienvater der sich vorgenommen hat mit 50 finanziell frei zu werden nichts desto trotz
haben wir für ihn jetzt auch mal mit 35 gerechnet er verdient unglaubliche 12.000 euro im monat ja
solche personen gibt es tatsächlich und legt davon fast die hälfte auf die seite dann kommen wir
das kann man 12.000 euro auch machen verdienen nämlich ein paar bestehend aus einem 33 jährigen
informatiker und einer 29 jährigen pharmazeutin zusammen verdienen sie über 14.000 euro netto
von ihnen wissen wir auch dass sie ein startkapital von 156.000 euro besitzen was wir mit in die
berechnungen einbezogen haben wir sehen also hier extrem hohe gehälter und extrem hohe sparraten
nicht umsonst sind wir in der kategorie der high earner was man aber mit berücksichtigen muss ist
dass in allen vier fällen die personen noch mal deutlich näher an den 35 jahren dran sind als bei
unserer jungen frugalistengruppe das bedeutet sie haben also auch weniger zeit das entsprechende
vermögen anzusparen um dann mit 35 finanziell frei zu sein und das ist auch der grund warum
in allen vier fällen die finanzielle freiheit mit 35 nicht erreicht werden kann es ist halt
fragwürdig ob die dann wirklich wenn du wenn du so ein krasses gehalt hattest auf einmal mit 2000
euro dann da zufrieden bist ja ich lente euch jetzt hier einmal das endvermögen ein das in
allen vier fällen erreicht wird und mit welcher monatlichen verrentung man hier rechnen kann diese
liegt in allen vier fällen unter dem aktuellen budget machen wir daher eine vierte rechnung auf
und weichen einmal das kriterium der 35 jahre auf genau das ist ja das weiß ich gerade mein ok
das ist weniger als das was sie aktuell brauchen
nein nein nein nein 12.000 euro im monat waren zwei personen zusammen rechnung auf und weichen
einmal das kriterium der 35 jahre auf und die hatten ja wir gehen noch mal kurz zurück zu der
zu der familie ach moment alter warum hat er ok ok also entweder ist das ein schweizer
also 12.000 euro netto im monat das ist schon heftig was du da kriegst mann ich mein what the
fuck im neuen job ist schon ganz ok was ich verdiene aber das ist weit davon entfernt
der macht bestimmt auch kubanedes vielleicht ist es vielleicht ist es seine
eigene firma und die geht voll steil keine ahnung
der verdient 20.000 euro quasi dann im monat wenn überhaupt 20.000 20.000 mal 12 es ist halt auch
240.000 euro im jahr jahresgalt naja je nachdem was es für eine position ist ist das ja durchaus
immer mit 33 ist das schon extrem viel ist das ja durchaus möglich wenn je nachdem was das ist
das ist ja nicht ist ja nicht gesagt dass der hier tagtäglich hier kubanedes administriert
sondern es kann ja durchaus sein dass da dass der abteilungsleiter ist oder so was dass der
dass er vielleicht in einer firma sogar abteilungsleiter it oder so was in der
richtung ist das kann ja durchaus sein oder es ist halt was super krass vielleicht der
cobalt entwickler was auch immer weniger zeit das entsprechende vermögen anzusparen um dann mit
35 finanziell frei zu sein und das ist auch der grund warum in allen vier fällen die
finanzielle freiheit mit 35 nicht erreicht werden kann wir blenden euch jetzt hier einmal das
entvermögen ein das in allen vier fällen erreicht wird und mit welcher monatlichen
verrentung man hier rechnen kann diese liegt in allen vier fällen unter dem aktuellen budget
machen wir daher eine vierte rechnung auf und weichen einmal das kriterium der 35 jahre auf
und geben jede 35 jahre ist bei mir schon abgefahren ich bin 38 jahre zeit das bedeutet der cutoff ist
hier nicht 35 jahre sondern das aktuelle alter plus zehn jahre in diesem fall steigt natürlich bei
allen vier noch mal das endkapital stark an und dementsprechend auch die zu erwartende rente der
familienvater der mit 50 finanziell frei sein möchte kommt auf ein vermögen von über einer
million die junge familie sogar über zwei tatsächlich reicht es aber in diesem fall auch
nur bei der jungen familie dazu finanziell frei zu sein nach diesen zehn jahren also dass sie sich
quasi ihren aktuellen lebensstandard aufrechterhalten können durch das angesparte kapital übrigens das
budget der jungen familie haben wir uns ebenfalls mal auf überfluss angeschaut schaut gerne mal
vorbei bei den anderen drei würde es natürlich helfen wenn sie ein startkapital zur verfügung
haben der researcher bei microsoft in zürich dem fehlt eine million bei microsoft so so leak
das startkapital bräuchte um tatsächlich in zehn jahren die finanzielle freiheit zu erreichen
alternativ könnte er natürlich auch an anderen stellschrauben arbeiten beispielsweise sein aktuelles
budget reduzieren und somit seine sparquote etwas erhöhen wie gesagt das aber auch nur unter der
bedingung dass er das ziel hat in zehn jahren finanziell frei zu werden das muss ja überhaupt
nicht seine ambition sein jetzt haben wir abschließend noch einmal für unsere acht
kandidaten durchgerechnet wie lange sie denn mit ihrer aktuellen sparquote bräuchten um die
finanzielle freiheit zu erreichen unter der bedingung wie gesagt dass ihr budget konstant
bleibt also das was sie zum leben brauchen bei den jungen frugalisten haben wir angenommen dass sie
monatlich ist auch so tolles wort 1000 euro zum leben brauchen da ihre aktuellen budgets
wahrscheinlich nicht langfristig realistisch sind wenn die kapitalmärkte wirklich so laufen
wie wir das jetzt hier simuliert haben dann würde die junge familie am schnellsten die
finanzielle freiheit erreichen nämlich in neun jahren am längsten nämlich 31 jahre bräuchte
unser researcher aus zürich das soll jetzt aber überhaupt keine wertung enthalten denn er wäre
damit mit 58 finanziell frei und könnte sich einen sehr sehr süßen lebensabend finanzieren alle
anderen kandidaten 58 ist ein gutes ist ein guter zeitraum zwischen diesen beiden extremen ein so
weit unsere modellrechnungen kommen wir mal zum fazit was das denn jetzt konkret für euch
bedeutet zunächst einmal sehen wir dass die finanzielle freiheit gar nicht so einfach zu
erreichen ist besonders hilfreich ist es wenn zwei faktoren zusammenkommen erstens mal ein sehr
hohes gehalt und zweitens ein sehr frugalistischer leben wer hätte das wer hätte das gedacht jemand
der viel verdient und kaum was davon ausgibt hat bessere chancen zu sparen das ist ja klar allen
acht beispieln die wir angeführt haben waren die sparquoten schon sehr sehr hoch und deutlich
überdurchschnittlich zur deutschen gesamtbevölkerung und auch überdurchschnittlich
im vergleich zu unserer finanzfluss community das bedeutet aber nicht dass ihr die fahnen den wind
hängen könnt und die finanzielle freiheit abschreiben könnt denn das ganze ist ja im
endeffekt nur ein plakativer begriff was ihr am besten für euch ausrechnet ist wie viel vermögen
ihr denn gerne hättet und auf dieses ziel hinspart die zeit spielt hier für euch wenn ihr weniger als
zehn jahre habt dann wird dieses ziel sehr wahrscheinlich immer sehr ambitiös sein und
auch vor allem durch die zufallsbewegungen an den kapitalmärkten getrieben sein wir haben
jetzt hier einmal mit einer sehr sehr starken vereinfachung von sieben prozent rentite pro
jahr gerechnet diese sieben prozent pendeln sich aber nur im sehr langen durchschnitt ein also
über 20 oder 30 jahre abschließend möchte ich dazu auch noch mal sagen dass finanzielle freiheit
oder ein gewisser vermögensstand kein endziel ist sondern ihr profitiert auch schon auf dem
weg dorthin massiv von dem was ihr euch auf die seite gelegt habt es geht hier nicht darum einen
gewissen top voll zu machen oder ein gewisses lebensziel zu erreichen sondern der weg des
vermögensaufbaus ist genauso interessant ihr lernt dabei extrem viel und werdet deutlich an
selbstbewusstsein gewinnen wenn ihr mal die ersten tausend und dann zehntausend und vielleicht auch
mal mehrere zehntausend euro auf eurem depot liegen ja mit sicherheit ich meine du weißt vor allem
selbst wenn du jetzt kein bock mehr auf deinen job hast du bist nicht sofort unter der brücke um es
übertrieben zu sagen wenn ihr selbst mal ein bisschen mit den zahlen spielen wollt und selbst
mal für euch rechnen möchte dann findet ihr alle wichtigen links unten in der video beschreibung
sowohl unser finanzfluss diagramm rechner der euch dieses schöne diagramm erstellt als auch
unseren finanzielle freiheit rechner oder unseren zinseszins und sparrechner wo ihr noch mal mit
etwas mehr annahmen kalkulieren könnt ich bedanke mich dass ihr das video bisher gesehen habt schreibt
uns gerne mal in die kommentare was eure finanziellen ziele sind und gibt uns einen daumen hoch wenn
euch das video gefallen hat und wenn du das erste mal auf unserem kanal ist würde ich mich freuen
wenn du uns abonnieren ok ich kann es mit 35 schon mal nicht mehr erreichen dazu bin ich zu
alt macht das diagramm mal ok wo gab es das ich kann es aber gar nicht machen weil ich meine
ausgaben nicht genau nicht genau weiß in diesem video wo war das hier mit 500 wo ist das diagramm
ich glaube ich muss euch flash bang
egal so das ist netto ja das weiß ich ja noch gar nicht genau also ich rechte mal mit 110.000
ungefähr brutto ich meine es schwankt halt habe ich euch ja schon im video erzählt es kann zwischen
zwischen 95.000 und 150.000 also ich sage mal 110 ist wahrscheinlich mit bonus halbwegs realistisch
kannst du das verlinken ans fluss.de rechner so also sprich
weiß nicht was dann auf dem konto rauskommt also ok ich muss das immer das da also ich kriege
dann mal 0,8 also 88 ich arbeite ja nur vier tage
ok komm wir retten wir rund mal ein bisschen auf 90.000 durch 12 7500 und davor muss ich
jetzt noch steuern bezahlen also sagen wir mal irgendwie was bleibt da übrig
Leute 4000 ungefähr 4000 ungefähr so irgendwie so
irgendwie so in dem dreh wird es wahrscheinlich hängen hinkommen ja weitere einkünfte youtube
stellts ja ungefähr ungefähr 20.000 sagen wir mal so in dem dreh durch zwölf
ja das mit steuern keine ahnung das macht man ins letztem macht man steuerberater also ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal irgendwie sowas noch so
ok ich bezahle ungefähr 1000 euro im monat
das über den daumen gepleilt ich kann es jetzt ja gar nicht genau wissen
so
ja ich gebe ungefähr 1000 euro dabei
ja was gebe ich aus ja ich gebe echt nicht viel aus also
ich komme insgesamt
keine ahnung wenn ich ich gebe ich gebe nicht auto ist auto ist zu wenig
ja das ist bei mir ein strom mit drin das auto keine ahnung ich habe wirklich keinen plan was
ich im monat so ausgeben nicht viel nicht vielleicht 500 euro oder so gibt nicht viel geld aus keine
ahnung ich habe täglicher bedarf moment täglich täglich täglicher bedarf ist ein bisschen so krass
alter ja jetzt ich habe jetzt aber ich gebe 1000 monat aus ich gebe echt nicht viel aus also
ich gebe ungefähr das aus was ich mit youtube verdiene das kommt ungefähr tatsächlich sogar
hin im durchschnitt glaube ich ok sparen ok wenn ich so viel ausgeben ok
ich könnte kann ich könnte 3000 euro sparen ich habe wirklich kein plan ich trage jetzt mal
irgendwas ein so irgendwas über den daumen echt kein plan und was passiert da jetzt
berechnen
die summe deines budget ist ok
sparen
und was sagt mir das jetzt die summe deines budget
ja ok
mieter
ja und jetzt
also und was macht was habe ich da jetzt davon
aber das war es einfach ach so ich dachte da kann man irgendwann ausrechnen ok das ist
quasi eher als es eher zum flexen auf twitter posten so nach dem motto ok
wo es bin ich habe den falschen link geklickt
ja ja mach jetzt nicht wie gesagt bei vielen sachen müsste ich mir auch
erstmal gedanken drüber machen ob das so stimmt wie viel es denn wirklich ist also ich habe da
überhaupt keinen überblick so richtig ich weiß ich weiß nur dass es eigentlich überall immer
und dass ich so gut wie nix nix ausgebe also ich meine ich kann ich kann euch ja mal sagen ok
amazon ist jetzt ein schlechtes beispiel weil ich vorhin das ipad gekauft habe aber allein
schon das ist ja quasi mehr ja or das kann man nicht bei amazon gucken your orders from keine
ahnung 2021 so
ane das kann man nicht zusammenrechnen ich hätte jetzt mal gerne den
gesamtbetrag gesehen bei amazon ja ok
ich muss mal kurz gucken
das andere konto macht das business bussiness konto
ja
akka haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes
was
ja
ich gehe nur nicht gleich essen
kontrolle
ah einer von der bahn
einer von der bahn kontrolle beim güterzug als wagenmeister excellent
ja
da gucken wir uns doch mal an was der wagenmeister so verdient
wenn man einmal nicht aufpasst hat man mit seinem leben
oder mitgekickt
da ist so eine sicherung raus
ich verliehne gut das weiß ich
hallo ich bin der jam zeltag 36 jahr alt aus leverkusen bin vom beruf wagenmeister im güterverkehr
und heute nehme ich euch mit auf eine nachtschicht von mir na dann
meine aufgabe als wagenmeister ist güterwagen vor einer zugfahrt zu untersuchen auf
verkehrstauglichkeit und getriebssicherheit okay sarex mal gucken aber nicht jetzt
die zu umfälle führen können ausgeschlossen werden können
hallo mustapha einen kaffee muss mindestens vor der arbeit garantiert sein kann man nicht auf
45 werden je nachdem wie ich zeit habe wenn ich natürlich viel zu tun habe dann kommt die
arbeit vorher vorher und dann trinke ich manchmal auch nur einen kaffee danke dir dankeschön
so dann geht's weiter
ich bin ja meistens auf abruf muss ich verschiedene orte fahren um züge zu untersuchen und der nächste
zug könnte auch sogar in leipzig sein dann müsste ich eventuell dort hinfahren und
dann wäre es schwer dass ich mit der bahn fahren müsste
ja das ist blöd weil man mit der bahn zur bahn fahren muss das stimmt schon der nur traurige
musik gern hört und traurige musik tut mich aber generell wieder muntern ja also ich höre traurige
musik wenn ich gut gelaunt bin das hört sich verrückt an was hört er denn so
das ist doch das ist doch irgendwie aus so einer vergangenheit epic music mix
ich habe die jungs wo ich mein geld nicht bekommen habe und auch nicht geschätzt
worden bin in meinen alten anderen berufen ich war hier immer so der laufbursche und in diesem
beruf man ist mittlerweile ein fahrperson der entscheidungen trifft und hier wird man mehr
geschätzt dann willkommen hier bin ich halt gerne um zu sehen wie es meinen freunden geht und sich
auch wieder mal ein bisschen gute laune holen ich hatte meinen vorigen job als anlageführer
verloren ich war arbeitslos war verzweifelt habe zu meiner frau gesagt lasst uns nach köln ziehen
und dann jeder zur bahn unterwegs hat ein sehr guter freund von mir angerufen hat gesagt schau mal
wer nicht wagen meister was für dich und ich dachte was ist ein bademeister und ich habe dann
wirklich blind mich auf diesen berufsweg gemacht und ich bereue das kein bisschen habe das noch
nie bereut gott sei dank hallo jungs hallo wie geht es euch alles gut küsschen küsschen ich
hasse sowas ja komplett so dieses wenn die leute sich so nahe kommen und so küsschen links küsschen
rechts habe ich immer nicht mit jetzt auf zum zug
generell sind guter bahn für am rande von industriegebieten deswegen sind die abgelegen
weil sie auch von menschen bisschen weiter weg sein soll
schlechteste wäre natürlich jetzt dass ich einen schaden finde und so ein schaden das der
wagen ausrangiert werden muss ich war jetzt auch auf mein kollegen den lochführer dass
er mich anruft weil er wird jetzt den zug mit luft gefüllt quasi dass die bremsen
funktionsfähig werden und dann werde ich mit ihm die untersuchung gleichzeitig die bremsproben
macht grüß dich ich merke auch dass er schon gelöst hat ich kontrolliere mal einfach mal
dagegen kippen ok ich warte mal wenn ein zug nicht kontrolliert wird kann es unterwegs zu
einem entgleisung kommen und es kann im schlimmsten fall passieren während ein
personenzug vorbeifährt so könnten sehr sehr viele menschen in gefahr kommen und im schlimmsten
fall gott sei schützen auch tödliche verunglücken und das versucht man zu minimieren indem man diese
kontrollen macht so es hat gelöst hat ja auch gemerkt hat beim gelösten zustand hat es er so
geschalt und wenn er angelegt war war ein stumpfer ton dafür kriegt man auch irgendwann das ohr
dagegen gekickt dagegen gehauen dafür man jeder wagenmeister den ich kenne und ich auch
jeder hat so seine eigene technik deswegen kann ich einfach schon so wirklich wie fast spaziergang
vorbeilaufen so dass das auch irgendwann ein ende hat gibt es da nicht irgendwelche protokolle wie
was gemacht werden muss und abgehakt und meiner kippe da muss es doch irgendeinen standard vorgehen
geben so testet man eine bremse kann ich der eine dagegen kicken der andere dagegen leuchten andere
dagegen hauen dem zug bei dem wagen jetzt würde ich schaue ob er geschlossen ist und ob hier
irgendwelche risse sind ob hier die schrauben dran sind der bolzen beispielsweise vorher guckt
schon auf die puffer ob die höhen stimmen dann schaue ich beispielsweise auf die auffang
einrichtung ob man nachts mit einer taschenlampe wirklich risse erkennt ich auch die bremsen hier
ihre splinte dran haben ich kann nicht sagen dass es nur drei wichtige sachen gibt alle einzelne
teile sind wichtig da ist so eine sicherung raus das ist schon mal gut anscheinend gefunden
zu haben hier gibt es auch reingesteckt die nachts aktiv sind und manchmal davon ist ein
schotterweg wenn die dann laufen dann höre ich das ja da macht man sich schon gedanken ist da
eventuell jemand dann ist es schon ein bisschen gruselig ich meine wäre ich schon gerne alleine
vier manchmal mit in den wald oder mit den jägenden deswegen haben wir ja diesen kontakt mit den
kollegen dass ich mich anmelde und abmelde das ist auch sinnvoll mich wundert es überhaupt dass
sie das alleine machen dürfen dass es nicht immer zwei sein müssen gut die haben keine leute
gleich noch mal kommen weil hier ist der un-tafel zwar nicht beschädigt aber ab da darf nicht so
rum flattern er muss schon fest dran sein deswegen hol ich dann gleich spülkleber von
meinem auto nach der bremsprobe und beklebt ihn noch schnell erstmal eine runde heißkleber
drunter das wäre jetzt beispiel eine flachstelle das ist quasi dann so zu sehen wie eine gerade
fläche und während der fahrt hoppst er auf der gleise und das erstens ist es laut er hoppt es
kann dadurch zu einer entgleisung kommen deswegen müsste der wagen rausgenommen werden wie wir
hier sehen ist es gerade mal zwei zentimeter also zwanzig millimeter quasi weit unter dem
grenzmaß und somit gar keine gefahr und kein problem also wie hat er das denn jetzt gemessen
wie
was zwei zentimeter was
also zwanzig millimeter quasi weit unter dem grenzmaß und somit gar keine gefahr und kein
problem die fläche okay also ja das war ein fall aber aber was was hat jetzt gemessen ich
habe es nicht gecheckt was hat er jetzt gemessen ach dieses ok dieser dieser diese beschädigung
da am am reifen oder der reifen nicht am wie heißt das am rad
ja das war ein fall zum sturz kommen konnte ich bin gerade hängen geblieben aber gottseidank
habe ich mich festgehalten ja mein job ist für mich gefährlich weil wenn man unkonzentriert
sein sollte mal ein schritt zu viel nach rechts macht und ein zug fährt vorbei könnte man sehr
schnell von einem zug erfasst werden und wo ich dann untersucht habe in dem moment fahrt ein ic an
mir vorbei wenn ein ic oder ic an jemanden vorbei fährt dann hat das ein sog der zieht sich unter
den zug rein und ich hatte das in dem letzten sekunde wahrscheinlich noch rechtzeitig gespürt
habe mich so quasi noch den zwischen den puffern von unserem zug der noch steht geschmissen und
kam dann quasi eine gefahr wirklich wahrscheinlich sogar dem tod entgangen deswegen nicht nur das aber
zweimal schauen sogar 1000 mal schauen klingt gefährlich jetzt noch mal interessant hallo
grüß dich bin jetzt am ende vom zug lösezustand bis jetzt alles in ordnung bist du bereit für
ein durchgangsprobe durchgang kommt ja
druckabfall da
dann gucke ich mal ob er selbstständig angelegt hat
ja hat angelegt ich warte bis er löst
bei mir ist gelöst das hat man tatsächlich gehört das ist das klingt viel heller
ist auch dran danke bis dann tschau tschau bremsen ordnung auch der zustand der bremsen
sehr top gott sei dank und der zug ist gut zu go als wagenmeister habe ich als grundgehalt
3400 euro und mit zuglagen bin ich dann bei 4600 euro ja da kriegt wahrscheinlich auch
zulagen weil nachts und nebel einsätze
steuerklasse 3 wie wird man steuerklasse 3 muss heiraten wahrscheinlich oder
also finde ich auch und dafür versuche ich denen auch mein bestes zu geben so dann mal feierabend
da ich keinen weiteren zug habe den ich untersuchen muss warte quasi auf aufruf ich kann auch zu
hause warten weil der zug der entsteht entstehen kann kann auch bei mir in der nähe sein da bin
ich aber abfakt oder da bist du quasi die ganze nacht am rumfahren zu irgendwelchen zügen die du
kontrollieren musst und du weißt nie ob einer anruft so war das ist auch eklig es spielt keine
rolle wo ich warte ich freue mich jetzt auf mein warmes bett zu hause und dass ich endlich mein
füße hochlegen kann ich wohne in miete mit meiner frau und mit meinem sohn
deswegen steuerklasse 3 verstehe schicht aber jetzt sagt ich werde niemals 1000 euro für
kaffeemaschine ausgeben sagt er jetzt in der sendung wo davor glaube ich irgendwie zwei
oder drei typen irgendwie so eine so eine 8000 12.000 euro kaffeemaschine hatten ja dafür
werden wir ist nicht wert anfangs war alles noch super und neu und hat uns gelangt als
mannenbrau aber nachdem unser kind auch dazu kam jetzt uns langsam natürlich eng und deswegen
uns auf ein eigenheim in zukunft dass wir ein eigenes haus haben mehr platz wir kaufen uns
auch jetzt beispielsweise momentan kein neu mit einem überschuss von 940 wird das nix mit rente
mit 35 weil wir haben ein kleinkind der beispiel auch mal schnell so fast beschädigt seit ich
geheiratet habe auch nachdem mein kind auf die welt gekommen ist habe ich wirklich so mehr mit
meinem privaten ob es aufgehört manche schrauben gerne an autos und ich spiele die mit meinem
sohn und verbringen die zeit mit meiner frau und der rest arbeitet er als wagenmeister in
güterverkehr bin auch sehr zufrieden mit der ganzen situation wie es jetzt gar bis jetzt war
tos musik tos musik das muss ich ausmachen weiß der nie auf twitter
wie nix auf laptops geht meistens ohne probleme ich betreibe linux sogar auf einem surface book
der laptop das geht ok jetzt wissen wir auch was ein wagenmeister macht wiegt nicht was verdient
ein it consult das haben wir uns schon angeguckt war das nicht auch der den ganzen tag nichts
gemacht hat wo wir uns gefragt haben für was kriegt er noch mal kohle am schlimmsten war bisher die
die excel die die die die die excel gemacht hat den ganzen tag hier wo ich mir gedacht habe warum
verdient die überhaupt damit warum kann ich damit überhaupt geld verdienen finde ich jetzt nicht
mehr keine ahnung ne ne today machen wir nix ja die business beraterin die ganzen tag excel gemacht
hat ja ja mache ich also lesberry pie picos nicht sehe ich den sinn nicht drinne aber sps
habe ich ein paar zum beispiel im keller in dem ikea luftqualitäts sensor im badezimmer für die
waage ist gar nicht alle es sind auf jeden fall ein paar sps die ich im einsatz habe
die ganzen steckdosen sind ja meistens sp 2866 sp 32 custom firmware geflasht wobei ich das
komplett gekauft habe und dann nur noch geflasht habe aber sind auch sp 32
key
leute ich glaube
ich glaube ich gehe jetzt was essen
preske pippo pippo fett da machen wir jetzt wir sehen uns vielleicht noch mal mit nach kuba
ne des stells bis denn macht's gut zu